Cord to server music.
Okay.
I know that's not the right song.
Fuck did it go?
Oh uh,
and we drive passing.
That's not the song either.
Wait,
what was the song called again?
It's called fish paste.
Oh.
This was
jealous of us because I guess you pronounce it d and words.
It's die and w o r d
and it is in fact the shit is shit.
[inaudible] original man.
I love that chick's voice.
I love everything about her.
I love that.
Fucked up there.
Cut.
Fuck the show.
That crazy bitch.
Fuck.
[inaudible] dudes are like debating whether or not she's hot.
Oh,
she's weird looking.
Yeah,
but she's hot as fuck you man.
Fuck us.
Look bangs out.
Crazy bitch.
Crazy.
That bitch on a one to 10.
Uh,
did she seems like a seven,
seven or eight.
I can a strong seven.
I bet.
She's a lot of fun.
She makes up for it.
Since we're off air,
dude,
you're off air.
You're all fair.
Here we are.
We're on
took awhile.
It took awhile to,
for us to show up.
So,
so that album came out.
Today comes out today.
They're from South Africa and I don't know what the whole story behind them is.
It's like you hear that it's manufactured that they were part of other bands and
this like whole like,
you know,
there supposed to be like Cape Town white trash,
right?
Like this is sort of manufactured.
I also heard that one of their,
their,
their main songs,
uh,
was actually released early prematurely.
Like the,
the footage got stolen or taken from somebody that worked on it and re released
it early and that actually made them become popular.
Really?
Yeah.
So,
well man,
the first,
the Zeff side one,
um,
do you have that load,
that up Zeff side?
Yeah,
that's the first one that I ever saw from that.
It's so strange.
You have to see the youtube to really get an appreciation for what these folks
look like because the dude is like really tall and really skinny and he has
these crazy gold teeth in these tattoos that looked like they were just
scribbled onto him.
You know?
I don't know know if they're real tattoos.
Are those real tattoos?
Probably.
I mean,
is that really his real deal?
Yeah.
Maybe he's just a Thespian.
I keep hearing.
I heard you.
I heard he was like an art.
They were art school dropouts.
So,
okay.
I like this.
It might be like alternative art,
whatever it is.
It's bad ass.
I don't give a fuck if it's real.
He doesn't have to be really be dumb and crazy,
you know,
whatever he's doing,
that character is fucking brilliant.
Yeah.
You know?
But do you gotta do you gotta side?
Yeah.
Ife or Wifi.
It loads up cause it's,
um,
it's fascinating,
right?
You have to see the youtube.
Like I'll just standing outside with his granny and then I lived with my mom and
dad on the road.
And then your land.
This,
this is the one ghetto way of showing something guys been friends for how long?
Forever.
Yeah.
You gotta to get people most sick.
This bro.
Why you guys have internet or yeah,
just get on youtube and look up PC,
computer die.
Antwoord NSF sides.
[inaudible] gangster skill.
Here's my phone apart.
Are you around?
Yeah.
Okay.
So give me a wrap.
Do me a rap Dj hot deck.
Drop them off the fucking beatbox dog.
This was the one that was stolen,
by the way.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
Just going to ask,
don't be Saki [inaudible] this pops up for you.
Just like pick up the top [inaudible] digital zone.
Puck is dope,
man.
I love it.
I love his accent and I love it.
I love the whole thing.
Please.
Yeah,
that's it.
With boxer shorts in front of her.
It's swinging his dick and they're fixing those dick.
It's fucking great,
man.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
It's new.
It's something,
you know?
Yeah.
It's something real,
you know,
in this world of packaged bullshit,
over and over again,
some of these fucking bans that they're just keep pushing.
It's like,
what is this fucking bullshit on the highway to fuck?
Speaking of bands,
oh,
by the way,
we were sponsored by the flashlights.
We got off to a bad start here.
Avatar or not?
Not,
yeah,
it's hurts.
Alien.
Fuck a blue flashlight.
I remember talking about this on the podcast,
like,
could this be real?
I think it's right next to your chair.
Yeah,
sure.
It's right here.
And we were talking on the podcast after we saw avatar because I told you I
totally wanted to fuck that blue Chester.
She's bad ass who doesn't,
right.
I'm like,
why don't they make an Avatar?
Fleshlight well they don't,
they don't make an avatar flashlight.
Yeah,
this is definitely not,
I mean it is blue and it's an alien pussy,
but those are coincidental circumstances,
old type thing.
Chris,
actually,
so that they released that a couple of years ago before Avatar was even.
Yeah,
totally.
it's on the books.
Well,
either way it's awesome.
Yeah,
it's not avatar.
It's alien.
It's a slow at it is.
It's going to be a SMURF fleshlight next year.
You don't feel guilty fucking that too because it's not really a vagina.
You know what I mean?
Like you look at like the vagina flashlights.
Like why would this vagina be in a tube?
Right.
Well,
I wasn't making any sense.
I fucked a regular nine fleshlight pushing.
It was just an ass like a piece of ass.
Like,
like a,
it looked like a piece of Dexter meat.
You know that you're a fucking off and not as good.
No,
because that was actually weird to me now.
And they know what they're doing,
man.
Um,
so anyway,
are sponsored by them.
And what we were talking about before we got into that was this thing on the
highway today in Los Angeles there was a band and was the band called imperial
stars.
Imperial Stars.
Now I didn't know about this.
I lucky I missed this.
I didn't leave the house today,
but um,
when it happened apparently was these guys got on the highway and they did turn
there.
They're stopped their truck and turned it sideways so that the created traffic
jam and then they started singing the biggest piece of attention whoring may be
anyone's ever done stood on the truck playing music by the way.
Like they had like full now these dumb motherfuckers probably thought that this
was like,
this is like the opening scene in our movie,
man.
This is it.
It's like they were so wild.
Like this is how they got discovered.
They got on top of the truck and they stopped traffic and the fucking music was
so good.
People didn't care,
man.
Yeah,
you get it.
and the crazy thing is,
is they actually,
I listened to the song,
I don't know if you've heard it.
I have not heard if I want to hate them.
I know.
If it was really good,
I would have been like,
damn,
there's no way.
It could be really good.
Because if they were,
it was really good.
They wouldn't be willing to do this.
It just makes you have to be a Douche bag.
You have to be a Douche bag to want to stop traffic and get on the news and do
all this at other people's expense.
Right.
Because you want to be known for your fucking music.
Fuck you.
Especially in this city where that fucking is.
Yeah.
Well,
what about people who are on the way to the hospital?
What about people were on the way to serious emergencies?
What about people that lost their job because of you?
That was the one day they were late again over the mark [inaudible].
You know,
maybe they had a fucking thing.
If you're late again this month you're fired and they were fired because you
fuck you dude.
Even if the song is all about traffic on the one on one,
that's the bad thing.
The song is all about him and what sucks is that every news place it's going to
talk about this and you know,
there's so many dumb asses out there that's going to like fall for this whole
trick and they're going to become their,
their Twitter count went up today.
How much I'm going to bet that I maybe,
I'm sure they did.
I'd probably follow them.
Listen,
I would have hoped for this.
They'll say something really stupid,
but I mean we just have to discourage that kind of shit.
You can't do that man.
You can't.
You know,
it's one thing if you want to do something for publicity and it doesn't fuck
with everybody else's life,
but when you want to do something like that in La and you want to stop traffic
just so that you get attention essentially like this is how we're going to make
it,
man.
This is,
it's a brilliant publicity stunt.
Like you guys are idiots.
That's an idiot move,
man.
It sucks.
And look,
you know,
maybe a bounce back from it and you maybe you fucked up and maybe you guys were
all high on coke and it seemed like an awesome idea.
I'm not saying your shitty human beings.
You fucked up though.
You want to hear this song flooded?
Huge.
Could take this piece here,
this fucking song.
We are going crazy.
Okay.
All right.
This all right.
Now actually I got,
hold on,
I forgot.
I can't do that on this computer.
Remember?
Oh,
that's right.
You can't get to it on an iPad.
Uh,
yeah.
Hold on a second.
So I,
uh,
talk about some joy.
Listen man,
I totally understand the appeal for all of these reality shows where all these
people become famous for no reason.
And then people go,
fuck man,
it's all just about getting eyes on you.
And then once you get eyes on you,
you can be a business and you can even use that for good.
You can go all Oprah style and fucking save the world with all the money.
You know,
maybe Kim Kardashians going to do that.
So maybe all of this will be kind of a good thing.
But d because of that,
people are trying to find ways to get attention outside of the normal shit
outside of being recognized for something recognized for what you do.
You know this fucking d at word is perfect.
However you say it.
Diane would die at word Diet that that rap band we were playing at.
We don't,
we haven't,
there's no publicity stunts.
There's nothing.
They didn't fucking start a fire in a mall.
All they did was make badass music and it got on youtube and everybody's like,
dude,
this is the shit.
Check this out.
This is fucking cool.
It's real smart.
They did it to the whole clip is like two minutes long.
Is this the song?
Yeah,
Dude.
And it's really poor greenscreen effects.
Okay,
so it's a
[inaudible].
This is really low.
Can we turn it up?
I've got your number.
I've got the energy to get to watch me.
The energy and
it's a perio by can you stay with y'all?
Can you shut down the thing stuck in traffic or something.
So it sounds,
you know,
it sounds like to me it's like a fake video used inside a movie.
You know,
like tropic thunder,
look at this new video that's on it's own.
I know.
That's what it sounds like to me.
That's a perfect way of describing it.
Dude.
That is the perfect way to describe I fake videos.
They're playing musicians,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
They do look like you even had a wig on too.
Yeah.
Well he's got fabulous hair.
Don't hate,
I think,
um,
yeah,
they're,
they sound like they're playing musicians.
I just hope there's no trying to get famous.
It wasn't bad.
I mean it was,
I couldn't say it was terrible.
I just hope there's nothing like copy catters you know,
like open Mike Acoustic people,
you know,
putting our bikes in the middle of highway.
Oh
No.
Fuck people,
we,
that guy might have started something and I know the economy is bad,
but what the fuck people,
yeah.
You know,
jam.
What if that does happen?
What if people start doing that all the now?
I think they're going to make,
make an example out of these guys,
they're probably going to charge them a lot of money.
Yeah.
Well what if it's nothing?
What if it's like,
no,
it's gotta be something that's gotta be something big because they blocked
traffic.
That's like a felony.
I think what they did for publicity's,
I think it's fairly serious,
right?
I think,
um,
I think they could go to jail.
It's very possible that you go to jail for something like that.
Yeah.
Like unlawful restraint.
You're an offeree saying,
yeah,
you could put like a kidnapping charge on danger to you.
Put human beings in danger,
close off the highways and make,
make it tough for people to get around ambulances.
You know,
someone's dad could have died because you know,
there's a heart attack and they rushed him to the hospital and they can't get
there in time because you fucking decided to sing in the road.
You cunt.
Fuck you.
You know,
that's just dumb.
And everybody,
you know,
everybody should react the same way to them.
Even if you like them.
It's like if there was a dumb move,
man,
there's just something so not cool.
Something should start from this.
Like it's a new tradition.
Every time you see these guys in public,
you have to throw a tomato at them.
They should charge them for everybody that was late.
Think about all the people that relate thousands and thousands of people that
were late there.
Their employers have to pay the person for the time that they weren't even at
work because they were stuck in a traffic jam because these assholes,
they should all like that shit.
Like they could just stack all that up.
They should like find out,
okay,
what do you get?
You get $50 an hour.
All right,
this guy gets 20 bucks an hour and this guy got okay,
45 minutes and we'll calculate it up and you know,
and Oh,
you owe $1 million.
You fuck.
Yeah.
This guy was auditioning for iron man for he could've made this much money on
it.
Yeah,
you crazy.
Yeah.
I could get crazy.
Like I had a fishing in a dream.
I knew it was going to happen for me.
Everything in my patient was absolutely perfect and true.
Except you,
you decided to sing on the fucking freeway.
What would have been smart if they hired these guys at,
these guys were homeless guys and they were,
they made like this fake video up just to make it look like they were the ones
singing.
But the real band hired these people to get in trouble to go to jail so they
wouldn't get in trouble.
And the,
the problem with a band like that,
it's that anybody that would come up with a stunt like that is not going to be
good.
Right.
We're just not going to be good.
Cause they obviously aren't famous yet.
What's not even not that you're not famous yet,
obviously there's a lot of good bands that aren't famous.
It's a being famous in the music business as a fucking weird thing.
It doesn't really make sense.
It's not that easy.
It's tricky,
you know,
it's like,
but with the Internet,
like look at this Dna ord thing,
you can get famous.
You just have to put something together.
And their show was cheap.
I mean,
it wasn't,
there was enough hand,
high tech,
nothing to it from South Africa.
We know about how Sally Mann and they did,
they,
they did it right.
You know,
it's,
but it's,
it's tricky like to try to like get record sales and shit and,
and get in the door and get played on the radio and everything.
It's like,
man,
it's so,
it's a fucking funky business.
And it got gutted because of the MP3S online,
like the music businesses in a state of shambles.
You know,
it's interesting with something like this,
Dee aunt word comes in and shakes things up,
but it's annoying when you see the other manifestations of it,
like these assholes with their fucking bus on the highway.
Right.
It's just,
it's just sad that someone would decide to do that.
That you would be so fucking selfish and stupid.
You would want to block off a main route just so that you could,
you know,
make it,
man,
the kid fucking make it mean.
What are the odds those guys aren't annoying as fuck his is a quote.
The band describes themselves as rock stars living on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
That's a real quote.
Shut the fuck up.
Swear to God.
Fucking La times.com.
I'm reading it right now.
The fuck up the band,
the band.
This is a subtle comedy.
Wait a minute.
I'm starting to like them.
I'm starting to become,
I think I just became a thing.
No Way.
Is it 180 degree turnaround?
This is a subtle comedy.
My bad internet.
This is a subtle comedy,
Dude.
No,
I think we're missing out.
We're missing out.
I'm on La Time Dotcom.
Where's this funny quotes about three sentences and members arrested after
blocking one-on-one freeway.
Okay.
That la times blogs and I want you to read it,
but I want you to read it.
How they wrote it too.
Oh my God.
Where's,
where's yours?
Is it the same day I emailed him saying he met it to you here.
You want to look at it right here?
Yeah.
Okay.
The band describes itself,
says rock stars.
Now this is in all caps with an exclamation point.
Oh,
living on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
Okay.
It says they debuted in 2010 with a hardcore hip hop album.
Well,
wait a minute,
are they rock stars or are they hardcore hip hop artists?
They can do anything.
That is crazy.
Is that a new thing that's going on now?
Like hip hop and rock?
It's just this all together.
It's just a setting in garage band nowadays so they can do anything they want
to.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
The band describes itself.
I'll say this again.
For those of you who haven't crashed your fucking cars and furious white
knuckled anger at these cuts,
the Ben describes itself as Rock Stars in there on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
That's a real quad.
If you seen the truck to that that was pulled over,
that was like,
oh,
it looks like Wayne's world
fucking picture of them.
It looks like something from Wayne's world.
It looks vague.
It doesn't even look real.
I hope this is not a movie.
Um,
it might be,
they might be brilliant.
It seems like it is.
Yeah.
Like I said,
like I said,
it seemed like a fake band inside of a movie.
Whatever the whole thing is.
I bet.
I bet it is.
There just is.
No.
Well,
if they are,
come on man,
then they're really fucked because if they make a movie and they closed the
highway down from movie like that.
Yeah.
No,
I don't believe that.
Because first of all,
you would have cameras everywhere.
You'd have real cameras.
You wouldn't have fucking little youtube cameras.
They're going to do a stunt like this.
They're going to have to have like real permits.
But look,
how could that photo is?
It's photos perfect.
They turn the car sideways,
turn it sideways.
That's perfect lighting.
It's perfect.
It even looks like it Kinda caught.
Dammit.
If this is a movie,
I'm going to be really mad and I'm already mad.
This devil mad.
Um,
I,
I'm hoping that these guys were like,
Andy Kaufman just is brilliant.
You know,
farmers,
artists.
No,
you're not like that.
Maybe the quote is so bad,
but so say it like Ben Describes itself as Rock Stars.
This is all in cabs living on the edge.
They're known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friend.
Right.
That's what they're known for is this guy in my neighborhood.
This guy is fucking crazy.
He hangs out with his friends.
That's how he's known that way.
Say It like you lived in Glendale though.
It totally changed the whole sentence.
You'll member walks.
Does,
we're living on the edge.
You know,
they're getting,
we'd like to get crazy in England.
People.
They were Flynn's man,
an Armenian guy.
You're doing what?
Does that make sense?
I don't have a Swedish Swedish.
Wow.
Um,
listen,
I think that these guys,
uh,
if,
if this is a scam and if this is just a,
a hustle,
then I dunno,
I'm on the fence.
I'm on the fence now.
It's not like you're going,
we decided to make a bad band on purpose.
I might think this is pretty fucking funny.
If the song was good.
That's what I was saying.
Remember when we went to see that band steel panther?
Yes.
That was good music.
Fucking awesome music.
If you haven't seen those guys.
Steel Panther or this,
they do this like eighties,
um,
thing where they play like all the,
like the best eighties rock and the,
the dude does the most insane Ozzy Osborne impression round and it's all like
hair metal stuff.
It's all like,
you know,
like it's good man.
It's good music but it's like this like hilarious good music parody on.
But you love it because you know there are fake band,
right?
You know,
but they're good.
These guys,
what if they are fake band too,
but they didn't do the good part of the music so it doesn't go together.
It doesn't work.
It has to actually cause cause I,
if I like these guys and I respect him actually have to get into their music and
I'm not,
what am I going to hang out with these guys and become friends with them.
But if it's just this brilliant performance piece,
which just make the worst,
most cliche,
do bland,
dumb wrap and we'll do it with like a lot of confidence.
Let's see if we could sell it.
What if they just want to make friends?
Maybe this is just a friend thing.
Like they,
you won't like the music,
but they just want to be your friend.
Well,
they do hang out with their friends.
They're known for that.
Right.
So known for getting crazy and hanging out with their friends.
So it's a,
it's a big frame thing.
How many people right now are going to change their Avatar,
their fucking signature under the advertiser on the road board now too.
He's known for getting crazy and hanging out with his friends.
You fucking dubby you shut up dummy.
It makes God dammit everybody's doe.
And they,
because of this ban Joey did wasn't here today.
Yeah.
This fucking band.
The,
these cut holes,
when they decided to do that,
Joey Diaz is a bit,
he was filming something today and he wasn't gonna be able to make it over and
time of traffic.
So we flew solo because of you.
You twats yeah.
Where'd it go?
Ah,
speaking of dumb,
um,
there's that guy who is running well,
he is,
I'm the Democratic nominee for Senate for,
I think it's South Carolina.
Yeah.
And His name is Alvin Green.
And this guy,
um,
he won.
Okay.
He won the Democratic nomination and a lot of people were thinking that he was a
plant.
They were saying there's something going on here because this guy is so bad.
Like it almost seems like the Republicans must've paid to get him in as the
Democrat.
Therefore they would run a posed for the Senate.
Like they would have this guy who was just like so bad.
It's impossible.
And He seems like a troll.
Right.
Really seems fake.
The Guy who is a military veteran.
Okay.
And he,
he did no campaign speeches.
He had no campaign events and he won.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean he won in,
a lot of people are saying the one,
cause he's black because they saw that he was black and black people just said,
well,
you know,
hey,
he's a veteran.
I'll vote for them.
So people were in,
the veteran's voted for him.
But when it comes to the guy talking,
dude,
it's one of the weirdest things ever.
It's almost like,
he's like,
it's like something is wrong.
It's not just that he's dumb.
It's like there's like a weird disconnect.
Like he's retarded.
What if it's something that like,
you're not allowed to say anything on this interview,
like the people that pushed him into no.
No.
You don't think there?
There's an,
there's a sheer pure idiocy to this guy.
Really?
That's shocking.
I'm going to hear this and this guy is a,
he goes on this talk show and they,
they ask them some questions.
[inaudible] plug it in.
I'll play this because it's so,
it's so trippy.
Yeah.
Turn your speaker so,
so hard to believe that this fucking guy so hard to believe that this force
[inaudible] Mute your Ustream.
Okay.
It's so hard to believe that this guy is actually running this guy for anything
you have to see.
It's very trippy here.
I'll plant.
It's very trippy.
Yeah.
Onto anything Brian.
That's the sound that the primary over a long a time democratic activists with
69% of the vote at the time though,
we're going to Greenland.
You still have a Ustream somewhere open?
No.
Okay.
It has to be.
How's it?
Why can't you plan on yours?
Um,
have you send me the youtube?
Yeah,
send me that link.
Uh,
oh Brian,
I thought you were going to be able to do it through this.
[inaudible] you ever used dream playing it?
That's why that echoing sound is going on right now.
Well,
it's this,
this,
this is what we're playing.
No,
no,
no.
There's a second window somewhere where you're Ustream is playing.
Oh,
it's probably this.
Yeah,
it's us.
This is the fucking Satish shit ever.
You people shouldn't have to listen to this answer this year.
And that is of course.
Are you a witch?
No.
First
I want to remind everyone that demand started the recession.
There you go.
You're on your talking points.
Not a witch.
And demand started.
The is the guy who's running against,
now you're saying to men started the resection.
Turtle.
Does that tell us you have to see what this guy looks like?
Does that tell us anything about how this race might end up?
Well,
dement started to recession dimension is responsible for the session and I'm the
best candidate that defines where we at right now in this country.
Um,
now I know people tell you,
you know,
no matter what the question is,
just do your talking points and all that sort of stuff.
But seriously,
Alvin,
your nickname,
turtle.
Um,
where did that come from?
No,
no.
Dummit started the reception and I'm the best candidate and that defines where
we had in this country.
I'm a United States army veteran.
Ones wrong are the concentrations on those efforts in,
and I'm an unemployed military jet or knitting currently and,
and we'll lose in this country is losing 100,000 jobs a month.
And,
and the is responsible for the recession.
Dimmitt Dimmitt started to refresh.
Uh,
okay.
Um,
what,
let's go to some debate positions and seekers.
You know,
if a white guys get this gas reporter voice shouldn't be allowed to be screwed.
Teachers in South Carolina.
Yes,
that's their private life.
And um,
none of their private life doesn't interfere with how they do their job.
Less so.
Could you imagine if that was your boss?
That's the crazy part.
Can't be real.
It's real as fuck.
So that'd be funny.
In fact,
on how will they do the job.
So that's,
that's,
that's fine.
And it's [inaudible] nomination.
What has gotten us to this recession?
So we just have to keep that in mind that the Mitt started the recession.
And how did it,
how to demand personally start the recession?
Good question.
Irresponsible spending.
Um,
um,
record cuts to education.
Um,
the um,
supporting the um,
Bush tax plan and
um,
mismanagement of the federal resources.
Um,
look at,
um,
the royals in the release that I'm just out and the wars and managed,
in Iraq and Afghanistan.
And um,
so we just see this irresponsible spending in this mismanagement of government
resources,
federal government and,
and just mismanagement of resources.
It's,
it's destroyed this country and I see that he's responsible for,
and that's fat Internet started the recession.
He's responsible for the recession and it doesn't make any sense then someone
back to Washington and just messing things up every day.
Well,
I gotta tell you,
I don't think Jim dement personally started the recession,
but I do think Alvin Green still better than Jim dement.
Alvin Green,
Democratic candidate set for Senate for South Carolina.
Thanks for joining.
He said he thinks he's better.
He's charming jr I'm guessing,
right?
They ever do not know they did that.
Dudes do that.
What did you say?
I think you're better.
I like you better,
obviously.
Probably if you hate somebody like anyone's better than this guy,
so anyone's better than the other guy.
The other guys are that bad,
I guess.
I guess this dementia real asshole.
Wow.
Dement you might've fucked up,
son.
If this guy beats you.
This guy just gets all the way through.
Fuck.
We don't know man.
She know.
That's what I've always said about Sarah Pailin.
When you know people talk about Sarah Palin stupid.
I'm like,
she's stupid to you.
Okay,
but if you're stupid than her,
you don't even know she's stupid.
And there's,
and there's a lot of people that are stupider than her.
Most people I think are stupid or than her.
It's like,
how many people are stupid than this guy?
This is the big question,
right?
Because if they are stupid than this guy and they've got to go for him.
I liked that boy,
that boy,
I speak the truth.
I won't go NASCAR.
That boy.
Yeah.
It's like no,
those people guy man.
Okay,
what guy am a boy?
Yeah,
but those people that Nascar people,
I think those are white people.
I think that's a different thing.
Is there a lot of,
well,
we'll Dale Wright who's black is a NASCAR fan.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Daryl Daryl loves NASCAR.
Weird.
You don't usually see that south park at it.
Their last episode is all about Nascar and that the stipulation was that like
any to be getting a NASCAR you have to be poor and dumb.
And that was the whole episode in Cartman's.
Like I could never be a NASCAR driver.
And you're like,
you could do anything you want to.
He goes,
no,
I'm not pouring down.
So it takes to start to taking badges hill and eating tons of fat.
So because this is slight memory loss,
you know,
it's one of the things to just fucking taking
seven bad.
Oh my God,
I've got to check out south park studios.com still to try to get dumber.
Yeah,
those guys are brilliant.
Yeah.
South Park Studios.
God,
they're alive.
Thank God they exist because of terrible didn't exist.
There'd be nothing like this week,
this week's about a jersey shore.
Oh,
I can't fucking wait.
I watched a whole episode the other day.
You know if Jersey shore still have never watched a whole episode,
I watched the whole episode.
Wow.
I was like,
this is fucking fascinating.
This is wild kingdom.
That's what this is.
This is just like watching wild kingdom.
I hate that shit.
I can't even get it.
Watch more than five minutes of that show.
Fascinating.
It's fascinating.
Can't help it.
It is.
What book?
What is the reason though?
Why do we fucking get glued to train wrecks?
You know,
like why is like the flavor flave show whenever we had those girls who are
trying to marry,
right,
or Brett Rogers,
you know,
watching the poisoned dude,
I'll know the bus of love.
Right?
What the fuck is it about those shows that would just suck up all your time.
There's,
they just fixate.
You just keep getting completely fixated on these idiots in their lives.
The problem though is a of those shows that even the Bret Michaels one had been
told is completely fake.
These,
they set it up and there's even a channel,
right?
Bret Michaels,
like married or something that he has a person that lives with him.
I don't know if he's married or it's just as longterm girlfriend that lives in
the house that they had the show on.
So this is all,
it's all just all fake.
A plot.
Totally.
It's like a reality sitcoms.
It's gotten so bad that there's actually a channel now called Tru TV,
which even has the word true in it and all their fucking shows are fake.
Like there's one about,
uh,
what's that?
Where you pawn shop,
a pawn shop,
something pawnshop wars show is fake.
Then there's one about guys that take cars when you owe money on a car,
a,
what's that called?
A repo man repellent.
It's like a repo man show and like they always get in fights,
but if you watch it every time they can fight.
Not One punch.
It's always pushing,
hugging,
grabbing,
throw.
No punches are thrown and it's like,
come on.
Just total horseshit,
total horseshit.
You could smell the acting with these guys too.
When you watch it,
it's just pure acting,
so all these reality shows aren't really reality.
They're not anymore,
man.
It's crazy.
Even there's,
you know what it is that is that production.
Like people get in say,
listen,
there's only one way to make this work.
Okay,
we can't just follow you around while you go to the mall.
Right?
You have to make things happen.
Okay?
We have to create some drama.
Do understand this.
There's an art to this.
Okay,
sit down and then they get them into some fucking conversation.
This is what we're going to do.
Like I remember Duncan was involved in the Polish shore one,
the the one that we're doing in mind.
Finding stories create things like,
like this is what you're going to do.
You're going to go out and you going to try and get all these different foods
for lunch and eventually going to get Mexican food.
Everything's going to go wrong.
Then you can get Mexican food.
Well,
it's the,
I think the simple thing is,
is that you have to do that because unless you had something like where we went
to,
like I used to film you every single weekend for three days in a row on tons of
hours of video.
Every couple months we'd get like this really cool 10 minutes or something.
Exactly.
You can,
you can't have every reality show and just like an hour every week.
This is not going to be that.
You know what happened?
Oh we had a show.
It was really good.
And then we've got some neat,
then we went to sleep,
right?
Cause that happens and look,
oh and then we played pool and Brian got bored and we went to sleep.
Right.
You look at the hills.
I mean look how successful the hills is and that's completely scripted.
There's even now there's a whatever,
16 and pregnant and teen mom and stuff.
And I always thought that was real.
I'm not 100% on this,
but I watched it the other day and night.
But I imagine the formula of the hills in it.
It's just like the fucking hills with teen moms and babies.
And I almost want to think that that shit is all completely famous.
Here's my problem with any teen mom show is that if you have a show where you
have some girl and she goes on and you know,
and she talks about how you know she doesn't want to give up her baby and she
was like 16 or 17 years old and just I'm going to do the best I can and you
know,
together we're going to be fine.
And then you have people going,
you're so strong.
I'm amazed at you.
I'm so proud of you and this girls on TV.
Do you know how many girls are going to get pregnant because they want to be
like that girl.
That's real.
Totally,
totally.
I mean this girl was irresponsible.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
for people magazine,
these,
that teen mom,
girl,
if you,
you should have something like that.
If you want to do something like that responsibly,
you should do it in like a DVD.
You want to do like a documentary on teen moms where you haven't,
you know,
you see this is what it's like.
It's very difficult and now you say,
but to have it on a TV show,
the problem,
the TV shows,
then it's on all the time they're on every week.
It becomes a part of your like programming.
You know when you find a show,
like whatever it is,
Dexter,
whatever it is you get into,
it's like,
oh,
it's fucking Monday night.
It's time for my show.
It's Tuesday night.
Right.
You get excited.
You know,
you get like into a little rhythm.
If you're getting into a rhythm with this fucking teen pregnancy thing and
you're 15 and you want to be special and you want to be like these girls that
are getting all this attention for,
for being strong and having their babies and showing how hard it is and see all
the drama and all the,
you know,
come on man,
what the fuck is that?
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
It's weird if you look at what your own TV shows,
because I'm,
I,
I'm addicted all the time.
Like I got to think they did that little midget show.
I'm like,
why the fuck am I care about?
Is a little midget shows small world are not smelling real.
But,
uh,
the one with the dad and the wife and they have all the kids and I've seen the
ads,
but I've never seen a show big people little road or something like that.
I mean,
it's obviously,
I'm sure it's a very challenging thing to be like that,
but you know,
have you heard that the show,
what is it,
19 and counting or 21 and counting?
No,
this is a show where the,
this is,
this husband and wife have like 19 kids are 21 kids and they all are
homeschooled and stuff like that.
And they,
uh,
the whole show is based on it and the,
the title of the show actually goes up every couple of years because they have
new babies.
Like they just had a new ones.
They changed the title of this show to like 21 in county.
Oh,
right.
Okay.
I know you're talking about this family is so fucking crazy.
I mean,
they're positive,
nice people.
So I don't want to bash your super nice.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's so crazy.
They won't let their kids outside wearing shorts.
Like you can't like have really religious.
Yeah.
Like you can't show like parts of your skin and stuff like that.
Sure.
About that 100% survey.
I,
that's one of those shows that got addicted to watching cause I liked the
positive vibe of the show.
So they're Super Christian.
What are they?
Super Christian.
Yeah,
the worst kind.
They seem really happy though.
You know,
it's like,
I understand that it's what they're doing as loony,
but,
and I understand that it's like a type of program,
but even when you get like you watch like real Super Christian programming and
action,
like the real shit,
I gotta go,
wow,
look how positive it is.
You know?
I mean,
look,
they're fucking,
they're making babies.
You know,
there's a lot of people that haven't fucked her wife 19 times ever.
Totally.
This guy's got 19 babies.
Right.
You know,
I mean for real,
there's one way of looking at it like that.
You could look at it like,
you know,
religion is just some sort of a way to stay sane,
like some sort of a path that you can follow.
Some people need it.
I think some people do.
I Dunno man.
19 kids is a motherfucker famous for that though.
You know?
I mean,
did they do drama in their shell?
Do they create fake drama?
Yeah,
it's totally fake.
Like it's not fake to the point where they're telling like acting.
It's for like today we're going to go riding here.
Like,
you know,
create events,
create reality.
Yeah.
Well that's kind of reasonable.
As long as it's not scripted.
I don't mind if they give them things to do,
you know?
But I don't want to watch you just cause you have a bunch of kids,
Yeah.
I'm sure it sucks.
It looks like it's crazy.
Like I used to watch John and Kate plus eight.
You know what?
I would think there's fucking eight kids that aren't getting enough attention.
You know?
That's what I would think.
I would get sad.
I was like,
you know what,
it should be like,
you know,
daddy should be able to spend some time just with you.
You know,
mommy should be able to spend some time just with you and when there's fucking
seven other kids around all the time screaming at Goggin,
how often do you ever get to sit on your mom's lap or what do you get a once
every five minutes.
You know,
they,
they switch people.
What do they do?
You get a four minute spot on mom's lap.
Yeah.
What do you have to like reserve like laying on the couch with your dad,
like watching TV for you to go to the iPhone genius store.
Genius counter and you have to give your name up when you want to get your
iPhone fixed.
Like what?
I have to make an appointment.
Can you just fix this?
That would suck.
It is.
Yeah man,
it's gotta be brutal.
It's gotta be hard for those kids.
It's cool.
I mean,
and much harder that they were publicly humiliated.
Like they,
they,
they were all together as this family and everybody's happy.
And then all of a sudden,
boom,
there's pictures of daddy with another girl and these magazines and daddy's gone
and daddy doesn't live in mom and yard and boom.
Now Mommy goes to California and she's on some fucking crazy dancing show,
you know,
and she's not home for like two months.
You know?
Why is everyone making fun of my dad's clothes?
Fucking,
you know,
they're just constantly just needy.
It's sad.
Kate plus eight now that's another name I was at the new show that's changed the
name,
does he?
He's not in it at all anymore,
I think.
I think he's like a bartender at the Applebee's now.
They shut him down,
man.
It's crazy that he was going to try to say that he didn't want his kids on the
show.
It's really quite tragic.
Like if you look at that,
the,
the whole story of them getting on that show,
their marriage,
you know,
the whole deal.
It's really tragic.
It's very tragic on him from his point of view.
It would be a fascinating fucking movie if he got real with everybody about what
it was like.
Because when,
when people first saw on the show,
like when I saw the,
uh,
the very first episode,
I only watched,
I think the first one was like a special and then it was so well received,
they decided to do a series.
Um,
and so they're,
they're,
you know,
they're together and you know,
she's this giant stomach and I mean it's crazy.
It looks like some sort of an animal's inside of her.
I mean she had like six babies in there.
I mean,
it's just enormous,
insane.
And when they showed them my taking care of the kids and everybody,
she's like always bitching at him.
Like,
oh,
always yapping at them.
Always done.
Well,
she's just conti.
She can't even help it.
Like with the camera's on,
it's just like,
whoa.
And I think that's so many fucking chicks must've seen that guy just seeing them
on TV and saw how she's treating him and must've been like,
you know,
I think it's bullshit the way she treats you.
I think you're really awesome.
I love the way you are with your kids.
And I would never cheat you that way.
Well,
you know what,
me and my wife,
it's a,
it's not really working out so good right now.
And next thing you know he's making out with her at a bar and get all sloppy
cigarette phase on her.
Oh,
the guy just started bawling,
man.
He was just like Chubby half Asian,
goofy looking dude.
You know,
it wasn't very handsome.
Wasn't ever too on top of that,
we went straight ed hardy out of box once,
once the show became successful,
he went crazy at hardy or it was like,
come on,
I get it.
The companion to wear the clothes,
you can wear something else every now and then.
Do they have Ed ed hardy water at my time at the store by my house.
And I'm just thinking like,
I hoped ed hardy dunked his balls and every bottle
bucks.
If you go out of your way to buy Ed hardy bought her.
I hope you're getting the salt from his sack is dipped into every fucking
bottle.
Can you imagine if you only drink ed hardy water?
Like he really were that big of a fans.
You remember?
Um,
what was that other brand?
Von Dutch.
Remember von Dutch Douche.
You remember that?
That was like the Ed hardy of the,
well,
the Ed hardy is the Ed Hardy,
the past and Hardee's gone right.
Pretty much gone.
They still have ed hardy stores though.
Yeah,
but people aren't really into it anymore.
It's like von Dutch.
It's like,
it's like this burst that just got an,
everybody's facing him like,
yeah.
It's like everybody gets excited and yeah,
it's a weird thing about like really trendy things like that.
Like the von Dutch thing.
To me it was very strange because people just love this logo that just says von
Dutch.
And they would wear it and I would be like,
okay,
I get it.
Sort of like,
what is it?
Is it looked cool?
Does it look old?
Tiny?
Like what is it?
What is it about that logo that makes you want to advertise this person's
clothing company?
You're just wearing a regular shirt.
It's just a shirt.
It says von Dutch on it.
Like in this like big,
you know,
it's like proclaiming von Dutch,
right?
Like this is weird.
And the hats.
Everybody was wearing these trucker hats at set on it.
I'm like,
I don't,
I'm,
I'm missing something here.
Like,
what do you,
why is,
why are people fixating on a logo?
And I,
I look that old navy,
remember when old navy first hit the street and everyone's like old navy and now
it's embarrassing.
Can you imagine being wearing an old navy shirt to weigh in at the UFC?
Oh,
the bad.
You can't work this old navy really big.
Oh,
well.
Like I never wore those,
but yeah,
I know what you're talking about.
Like a logo shirt.
Yeah.
Gap was another one word.
Like skin,
cause I,
you know,
yeah.
But that's cooler than fall into the gap with me.
You know,
logo.
I'll allow,
it wasn't under,
I don't think I'd wear a gap logo either.
I only wear logos if it's like dudes,
I know their shirt companies or something.
Chicken.
Oh,
higher dash primate is open.
Um,
and they're,
they're uh,
yeah,
I got 'em during the,
of the room there.
I don't have,
I should've brought them out for the podcast man.
Totally.
But,
uh,
so that uh,
it's higher dash primate,
is that what it is?
Yeah,
higher dash a in the Middle Dash I believe.
It's not one of those underscore dashes.
If it's a regular-higher-primate.com.
And this is my,
a clothing company.
You know what my favorite one is?
What?
It's the
one with the face that looks like,
uh,
like something crazy.
Tron type video game.
I don't know if you know which one I'm talking about.
Oh,
the the crazy monkey.
Yeah.
It's hired-primate.com.
And it's all like psychedelic inspired monkey stuff.
Yeah,
it's complicated.
That's the one I like,
which is what fascinates me more than anything.
Psychedelics and monkeys or I like the art.
Yeah.
It's the guys who did it or fucking Badass.
They did an awesome job.
They put together site too.
It's pretty sweet.
I wonder who these people are that are modeling your shirts though.
Freaks.
Freaks are crazy.
Tattoos.
That's what I like.
I told him,
get somebody that looks like someone I would hang out with.
His dirty bitch would have crazy tattoos.
I bet she's got some good stories.
Yeah,
but people like shit on them,
like on the underground,
like pupil or lose fucking Fergie fucking to twos.
His troops go loner.
Eh?
People are so negative,
man.
People are negative.
I've been experiencing much more negativity lately.
I think something's going on really.
I think there's a shift in the access.
I think the earth is going through a change.
Brian,
I think that's what 2012 is all about.
It's all happening right now.
I've been hanging out with happy people lately and it's just happy and life has
had the best mum.
The people I've been hanging around with,
I've been very happy,
but I've been noticing a lot more negativity online.
Oh yeah.
It's a lot of,
a lot of angry cut faces online.
Totally.
It's a unnecessary folks.
I'm those teacher gym.
There's teachers that you made,
I know they're going to make more,
or is this just like a.
Dot.
Yeah,
we're selling them now.
Let's go her clothing line.
Cool.
I'm a businessman now,
Brian.
That's cool.
I'm be involved in business.
I've already sold hundreds and I haven't even advertised hundreds.
I tell you.
Oh,
we shouldn't bring up Nick squirts and has a show coming out tonight.
That's hilarious.
You've got to check out loud with your friends are in it.
Nick Swardson's brilliant.
He's,
he's a great guy too.
And uh,
what's the show called?
Nick's silly.
What a play time I played to something like that.
Yeah.
Something in time.
How tell Nick Swardson Nick Swardson.
I love that dude.
They have this one skit.
It's all about a cat that was in,
that's in a wheelchair.
It's called trust fund and Katie and he's just like,
uh,
what's that guy's name with that has the robot voice that Stephen Hawking,
Stephen Hawking style where he has like,
hello,
how you doing and stuff like that.
And it's Nick Swardson doing that.
Fucking strange.
I,
yeah.
Pretend Times.
Wait,
it's called next worth and pretend time.
That sounds like a good idea.
Yeah.
For him.
That's a fun vehicle.
He actually has been busy as fuck.
I think he found like four movies this year.
So bad mother fucker.
Yeah,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He's a good dude too.
He's a great guy to hang out with.
He's a lot of fun.
Um,
so,
uh,
here's another thing that I want to talk about.
There's this guy got busted in Ohio and he's a tea party candidate and uh,
it turns out homeboy likes to trust up like a Nazi.
Um,
it's,
uh,
he's,
it's described as millionaire rich IOD,
a tea party back candidate.
He's been outed as a war,
an actor,
and he plays a part of a Nazi and he's been doing it for years.
And,
uh,
he takes his son and he and his son dressed up like Nazis.
Why listen.
And they,
uh,
they call them on it on CNN and when they call it on the,
they call them on it,
he,
uh,
he is very nervous.
It's very obvious that he's nervous,
right?
And it's very obvious that he's trying to like make paint this in the best light
possible.
But there's something wrong with this dude to,
okay,
I'm going to play this.
Okay.
Ohio Republicans learn something new about one of their congressional
candidates.
He has had a habit of dressing up as a Nazi.
This is handled hobby.
And third from the left,
you can count over with me.
His name is rich [inaudible].
He's running in Ohio's ninth congressional district and this Nazi thing,
not something he mentions on his website.
We checked it Lennik monthly reports that I,
it has done this for years.
Dress as a member of the Waffen s s and take part in Nazi reenactments.
I Republican rich IUT.
Good enough to join me.
I have to get the story straight from him.
Uh,
here in Toledo.
Mr [inaudible],
thanks for coming on.
Let's get straight out of the gate here,
sir.
Let me,
why Indian dress up as a nice evening?
Like a white haired Indian?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
for years,
going back to my college days,
I got involved in historical reenacting a doing civil war and I,
over the years I've done a civil war,
first world war,
Second World War and both sides,
uh,
you know,
union and confederate and,
and Ben Involved,
uh,
on both sides in historical reenactments.
Now the purpose of historical reenactment is,
uh,
is not to glorify war necessarily or the size.
What is to to educate people to learn about,
uh,
what happened and to keep those memories alive so that we don't,
we don't let it happen again.
Now let me interrupt you.
I know I was interrupting.
The reason
I would tell him,
dude,
you've got a weak voice,
son.
Yeah,
it's seriously,
what's wrong with just pictures of Hitler in reading about Hitler?
Why do you have to reenact it?
You know,
like,
yeah,
it's not that we're going to forget.
You're gonna like the way you talk either.
You don't talk very confidently,
sir.
You don't talk like a man,
right?
You talk about a week,
bitch,
we have Schindler's list.
Why don't you just let somebody watch it?
If they,
if they start forgetting,
just put it on center's list.
Eric,
you remembered while I've been involved in reenactment,
I just picture him with black socks on and nothing else holding his dick in his
hand doing something crazy.
Guys that do reenactments,
just gay hunters,
gay hunters.
How's that work?
You know,
like,
like the civil war guys.
Like what do they do?
Like the gay ones,
like rent,
do reenactments or who does these reenactments?
That gay people.
It's just people who are worn nuts.
What do you think,
why do you think the gay,
cause they're dressing,
they're,
yeah,
they're just an up and makeup and stuff like that.
Or Hey,
let's all right this time,
let's go around this side and go,
that's,
that is kind of funny that they do wear the outfits and everything.
They get so silly.
They bring their,
their like,
like actual,
like,
oh,
this is a powder bag that they would have used.
And he's so actual dimensions.
I sewed it myself.
Yeah.
I see.
There's sewing shit.
I made sure I got it.
Only with the natural leather.
A lot of times a you'd want to use chemically treated leather,
but that won't be authentic.
Exactly.
They're wearing wigs and fucking sewing and hanging out in the middle of a
forest re playing play reality.
I can understand being fascinated by history.
I've had a bunch of friends that were history majors in college and you know,
and they uh,
they get into like,
you know,
errors,
like some people are Greek history and it's fascinating history man.
A lot of crazy shit went down.
You know,
it's really interesting stuff to think that this was like,
you know,
civilization being born.
But getting into it,
I totally understand getting into the civil war,
it's fucking fascinating,
but dressing up and acting it out.
What's that all about?
Gay Hunters.
What is that all about?
And this is what we did.
Maybe you're doing it for your kids so they could see,
well this is what it must've been like back then.
Call it.
It's called call of duty.
Let the kid play call of duty.
So what the fuck people are all fallen down holding on to their chest and shit.
How nutty is it that America likes to fight so much?
We've only been around for like a couple of hundred years.
We've already fought ourselves,
you know,
that's how fucked up we are.
We have only been around for like 250 years or something.
Not even what was 1776 come on man.
We've been around for that long and we've very far so
that's funny.
We're fucking,
we're constantly are still fighting ourselves with shit.
Oh,
there's tea party bullshit.
I don't even know what they want.
I hate them because I hear them all the time and I see him in interviews.
I don't even want to know their position.
I think you're all cunts.
Where did these guys come from?
I haven't heard about the tea party since like elementary school.
Like people who don't like black people.
That's really what it is.
They don't want a black guy at office.
They're freaking the fuck out.
Look,
there's a bunch of extenuating circumstances as to why this economy is fucked up
and Obama is not there to blame nor to,
you know,
he's not like he's a one part of a giant fucked up system,
you know?
And yeah,
he's not doing a perfect job,
but who the fuck would,
this economy is fucked.
There's a lot of crazy shit going on.
They got got into officer's two wars going on.
I don't understand it.
None of it makes sense to me.
It's all chaos and you know,
people like he's not qualified and he wasn't even born here and blah blah blah
blah blah.
They talk on this crazy shit about it.
But the bottom line is nobody can handle this.
Who the fucking handle this.
You know,
they think someone's going to come in and fix this and having like this idea
that they're gonna like take back all these,
you know,
these,
these tax cuts and,
and and,
and start like ta one of their,
they start trying to do,
they're trying to like give the middle class a chance to rebound.
That's the idea.
Right?
Is that the idea?
I don't follow this shit.
You're losing that middle ground
because you don't follow it at all.
No,
of course not.
I barely follow fucking my favorite TV shows.
Well,
I know that there's a lot of issues about taxes.
They definitely feel there's too much taxes and then definitely
fillers,
too much spending and it's irresponsible and that's what's caused the economy.
You know,
I don't know if that's true.
I know that that's a part of it.
I know that for sure people being shitty with money has been a problem in all
governments.
It's always,
there was always corruption.
There's always money falling up,
but that's not exactly why there's economies fucked up.
This economy is fucked up cause it was based on bullshit.
This economy is fucked up cause there was a gigantic housing bubble that didn't
make any sense.
It's a fucked up cause we don't make anything anymore.
It's fucked up because we're going to Detroit,
we're going to do a UFC in Detroit.
Detroit's like 30 something percent unemployment.
That seems like the scariest UFC in the whole entire world.
Detroit's Grazie we in.
This is what's wrong with the economy.
The United States,
you know,
Putin said this once before the economy hit the shitter.
He said,
I don't understand the United States economy.
It seems all they do is buy and sell each other's houses.
So you know all these tea party assholes,
all this crazy,
we're going to do it.
And you know,
we're gonna fucking,
I mean,
I'm not even standing there.
Their positions,
I don't even know what the positions are.
I know that,
you know,
the whole idea is the same thing as what happened in the tea party of way back
when they want to overthrow the current government.
They want to put,
you know,
a better government in place.
They want to whatever the fuck they want to do.
What do they want to do?
I don't know.
Why are they so concerned about,
well anyway,
shit,
whatever the fuck they want to do.
This guy,
this guy wants to be a Nazi.
That's ridiculous.
That's let's do more of them because I'm not making any sense.
Okay.
I'm wrong.
Part of the reason you chose to do this is more of a teaching moment with your
son.
You participating with this group,
this weekend group.
It was also your son.
Is that right?
Okay.
Uh,
that's correct.
We did civil war together and uh,
we also did a World War II redneck.
We're reenacting.
Look at these crazy ass.
All right.
Together.
So has your son dressed up as a Nazi in addition to you?
Uh,
he's participated as well.
Yes.
Can follow up?
Where were you wearing your hands?
Question or two?
Let me ask you this.
How do you then explain to your son,
how old was your son when he was dressing up like this?
Okay.
Uh,
when he first got involved,
uh,
he was,
15.
So when his team,
and how did you,
and explaining why you would want your son,
um,
dressing up in Nazi uniform in ss uniform.
How did you explain Nazi-ism to him
here you were at Roddy.
He from an early age had been interested in history and because I'm a,
I'm very involved in,
in history and I'm teaching history,
uh,
and uh,
and learning more about history.
He had always been nervous as fuck and a,
on many,
many occasions we talked about,
you know,
the horrific things that happened during World War II.
[inaudible] terrific people.
One of the low points of a,
I think in,
in human history is photos showing of them all dress
up as Nazis smiling.
Yeah.
Sweep it under the rug with boners.
Did indeed happen.
Uh,
but it was very,
very much a,
we can't sweep it under the rug.
Low Point,
which I think probably many people,
many people who know their history would agree with you.
Was there any ever appoint Mr Iot where you said,
hey,
this isn't such a great thing to do.
You know what's the best thing?
This chick is hot as fuck.
Look at the chick that's asking that question.
We back that up a second.
She's like,
she's like weathermen and La.
Once shit gets down,
she can't.
She's got that hot when you blow the picture up.
Big unregular Ustream.
Ustream,
so she has her skin is so compressed.
See?
Well I think that's just that.
Okay sir,
you would agree with you.
Was there any ever appoint Mr Iot where you said,
you know she is hot as fuck,
she's hot as fuck.
Oh yeah.
That was just a bad angle.
Was frozen in a bag.
She seen me,
me,
this is institute.
Great thing you do and she's saying it with this beautiful face about the
tragedies happened Dervis years ago.
Creepy in a big closet.
Nazi fog and Ackman is education.
A lot of times if a store or in their pocket,
just that skirt,
that dude's wearing
exhibits and giving the public a chance to come in,
ask questions,
uh,
and,
and learn,
learn his,
listen,
this certain shit you're allowed to get away with in this life dressing up like
a Nazi ain't one of them.
Or is kilts.
I am tired of seeing grown men wearing kilts out at the mall and I am supposed
to just take it as,
oh,
it's a cultural thing.
No,
you look like you're fucking wearing a dress and you should not be wearing what
you care if he's wearing as killed.
I don't care if guys were killed.
Yeah,
but when you're at the mall hanging out,
you know,
I can see where you're like,
like playing a German bar and you're like,
like,
you know,
singing or something or,
but just walking around a mall,
it could kill you.
Why not?
Because it's a dress,
but it's so what?
Why can't I do wear a dress?
No,
it's fine,
but just let Julie know that I'm Jewish.
You do.
She is [inaudible] because he's not wearing the chose chosen garments,
garments to garments.
We all agreed on.
I will allow us Celt.
You will.
I will.
I'll kill.
So you and you would go with on them,
you would go to a UFC with a guy wearing a coat.
I don't know if you want,
if Doug Stan hope wanted to wear a kilt and go to the UFC,
I would go with him.
Okay.
For,
yeah,
for sure.
Any you guys sat next to each other?
Why not?
Who gives a fuck?
It's killed.
Really?
What is it?
Kill.
It's like a dress or would you wear it?
So what's the difference in that?
In shorts,
man.
Would you wear a coat?
I would wear a kilt for why?
Would have to do with it?
Yeah.
Wind blows up and then yours.
Everyone see your underwear.
I was,
see my Dick Yo killed.
You're not supposed to wear underwear.
No.
If you're going to be the fucking man and be walking around with a dress,
you've gotta go.
You gotta frame.
You've got gotta be free.
He just,
there's some things I just don't buy that.
But that to me is that like look at me attention to certainly is,
you know,
it's certainly not what I would choose.
I would choose to blend in.
Right.
But you know,
I mean if I had to wear it and wear it,
what'd you wear?
Capris?
What are Capris Capris or where they stay?
They go down right below your knee like right here.
Like pants don't fit me dude.
They don't make them my size.
I'm felt like a troll,
male Capris dudes that are built like me.
Troll like very chimpanzee.
Like I can't wear skinny jeans out.
Really?
They don't fit.
I can't get any of that fit me.
Yeah.
You like those,
Huh?
Skinny jeans.
Now I just try to have genes that make me look skinny.
Now
are you still rocking weight watchers?
Yeah.
Wow.
Um,
yeah.
I've been eating Vegan late.
Yeah.
Well Deacon Cox,
you sucked today.
The truth.
Not again.
I'm going to get so many emails that are angry at me for two reasons.
For one.
Does tea party thing,
cause you don't even know the position you have proven to port?
Of course.
I do.
You guys have Glenn Beck talking for you.
Okay.
You guys have fucking Sarah Palin and Glenn back giving big speeches and of
course I have a problem with you.
You sound like idiots,
but I don't know the position.
I'm not really that interested in to be honest with you.
So people are going to be upset me about that.
And the Vegan sucking cock thing.
Why?
Cause I'm just joking,
but people are so God damn sensitive.
You know.
Uh,
somebody sent me an email,
just dude sent me an email,
you know,
about how he was a very upset because uh,
I,
uh,
somehow or another equated vegetarianism to,
in,
in quotes faggotry but I don't really mean that,
you know,
when I say that it's just,
I'm just saying that,
you know,
like you're,
you're upset enough that you're gonna write something down.
You're a vegetarian.
You're offended.
I used to be a fan and like,
what are you on team vegetarian set that I'm shitting on vegetables.
Shit.
Why is that something that's crazy?
Like I would not be pissed if you hated Lasagna.
Made fun of Lasagna but joking,
you know,
if I say,
you know the,
you know,
you're vegetarian,
that is sheer faggotry.
Boy,
you need to get a stake in you.
Do you think I really give a fuck what you eat?
Right?
You know,
whatever you want,
man.
I'm just joking around.
I went on a Vegan kick just because,
uh,
last week that grocery store I went to,
they had New York strips usually for $15 each and I was like once in a while
treating myself,
I'll go get a steak.
They had this crazy sale like 75% off all their stakes.
That's never good.
I bought six steaks.
I fucking had like I had lunch one day and ate steak and then had dinner and
then create some nuclear meet boy.
I just couldn't get a giant sail.
I murdered animal meat juice.
How much they got leftover.
I don't know man.
I know it was last week,
but I ate them all.
Is that what you're talking about?
Yeah.
Do,
do you think something wrong with it?
Maybe it was just no,
no,
no reason there's no,
not at all.
They just had a crazy say on New York strips so they just had too many of them
and I get,
but at that $15 steak was like $4 so I was like,
I spent 20 bucks,
25 bucks or something ridiculous on state.
Where the fuck would we be without supermarkets?
If you ever thought about how difficult it would be to go hunt and get your own
food,
eating so many cats and dogs,
dude you'd have two cats and dogs would be,
you'd keep them around like like chickens,
you know,
I might have to eat.
You just stay right here.
You get a lot of meat off of a good dog.
Totally.
I was looking at this,
it's funny you said that.
I was looking at my dog's leg the other day was I was just like petting a
stomach and I just started playing with his leg and kind of like massaging his
leg,
you know,
just a nice dog stuff.
And I looked at his leg and I'm like,
this looks so much like a chicken leg.
You know,
like if you go to like,
and I was like,
wait a second,
I'm thinking like Elmer Fudd now,
you know like those old cartoons where they look at it like an animal and then
they turn into a Turkey.
I was doing that with my dog.
I was like,
what the Fuck's wrong with me?
And the Turkey always had like the bones sticking up out of the legs and there's
steam coming off of it.
Right?
Yeah.
I guess that's something really funny is we all grew up with those hyper violent
cartoons.
Right?
But today that you,
you can't make a cartoon like that are so pussy down.
The shit that we used to watch,
like,
like Donald would not know.
Who is it?
Daffy duck who used to get shot in the face all the time.
Donald or Daffy daffy duck.
Daffy duck used to get shot in the face all the time.
And it's fucking,
yeah,
he's be could be around the back of his head and he would have to turn it
towards the front.
And it would be funny.
It would be funny when you were a little kid.
I loved those shows.
The fucking road runner and wile e coyote,
Wiley Coyote was always getting fucked up,
dude.
He would always try to blow up bridges and shit.
He was a terrorist.
That fucking coyote was a terrorist all to get this one bird.
He was dropping anvils but it would always fuck up and crush him always.
And Pepe Le Pew has got laid even though he smelled.
That's true.
Pepe was always hitting it totally.
It was always sexual deviant that there's like a fucking pervert.
He was like a little day paper.
French.
It was right.
He wasn't like,
get all up in them and climb all on that.
If that was your fucking your cat and you know,
and this,
this guy is trying to fuck your cat,
that's fucked up.
Well back off,
dude.
Yeah,
that's wrong.
But you can't have a cartoon like that today.
Any of those cartoons.
You can't have bugs bunny.
You can't have.
We,
we,
we've toned back on what we allow kids to watch and see.
But does anybody really believe that watching daffy duck and shot in the face is
going to make people want,
Oh,
mine.
Obviously they have because they've edited in censored a lot of those tunes they
even take it doesn't mean it makes people do things.
Do you think anybody's ever done but violence because they watched daffy duck?
That's what I'm saying.
Well I think that,
you know,
they edited out cigars and cigarettes out of the old bugs bunny cartoons and I
could kind of see that because that's how I learned what a cigarette was back in
the dizzy you learned from bugs bunny?
Probably.
That's probably my first introduction to cigarettes.
Reimagine watch bugs bunny and like nonstop for an,
I was a kid,
I didn't know bugs bunny smoked a lot of cigarettes.
They always had cigarettes and gags.
Yeah,
like there was,
I don't know exactly which episodes and stuff like that,
but there has been sick tons of cigarettes in bugs bunny's and even like that
one dog,
the bulldog used to always have a cigar and stuff like that.
You know,
why is it that those cartoons are not offensive?
Even if you watch them now,
like if you watch Donald Duck,
if you're,
if we're watching a looney tunes cartoon,
it's kind of fun to watch.
Yeah,
there's still kind of fun to watch.
Right.
You know,
but like I guess it's cause it's animals,
you know,
it's not people for them and letting us Elmer Fudd but he wears,
he got was black face after getting shot and if,
you know what I'm saying is why,
why are they still entertaining,
you know,
do you think the cartoons of today,
I mean,
is anybody going to be,
could it be watching Dora the explorer when they grow up?
I don't know.
I think it's just because we grew up with it,
you know,
I don't think our kids are going to be as big a bugs bunny fans.
Are they allowed to show like all those violent ones,
like the end volts falling on people's heads?
Do they show all that stuff?
It's mostly like the cigars that their cigarettes,
they're taken out.
And when can you watch looney tunes?
Like is it on like cable or something and the cartoon network during the days,
stuff like that.
And so they'll play all the violent ones,
gunshots,
all that crazy shit.
Yeah.
But they've censored it so much that they definitely have a pilot that they
choose from,
uh,
in a pilot that they don't really show too much anymore.
Do you ever see the commercials where Fred Flintstone and Barney rubble or
sitting around smoking?
Winston's totally.
There's a lot of those commercials.
There's a lot of them.
There's a Winston Winston's,
and it was like,
uh,
maybe six episodes they did where they used to do commercials.
Like,
Hey Bernie,
is that a Wednesday and ulterior light?
So strange.
Did you know that they had to take out?
I don't know if it's just in California near that,
I think,
maybe not.
But they took lights out a cigarette.
So now there's no more Marlboro lights.
No more camel lights because they're not allowed to call it lights anymore.
Yeah.
The light thing was ridiculous.
It's still a fucking cigarettes and now it's like Marlboro silver or something
stupid.
Like,
really?
Yeah.
So what was the difference in light is that light tar is less strong,
but there's the,
it was actually just more holes perforation into the filters.
So what they are saying that you're sucking more air in and it kind of diluted
it.
But the problem is that some everyone smokes different.
So if I,
if I a wigger lipped it,
you know,
like as I'm a white guy,
if I'm Wingard lifted and covered up all the holes,
uh,
then in the light part doesn't work,
you know,
so it's the same tobacco,
same exact cigarette with just more perforation in the filter.
Wait a minute.
Really?
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
How many people buy it?
Like,
cause they just feel like that's,
it's not so bad.
Yeah,
it's nice people.
It's like diet coke.
Yeah,
I do it.
So there's no difference in the amount of nicotine?
Uh,
no.
Between the light and the regular secrets,
supposedly not.
Supposedly Tobacco's tobacco is,
I'm not a hundred percent sure,
but I know that's what made it a light cigarette was the holes,
the perforation.
The scariest thing to me about cigarettes is the 599 different things that
they've added to tobacco.
The cigarette company,
natural spirits is the one that brought that advertising campaign to it where
they just have this list of every single extra chemicals inside a cigarette and
they were like,
we only have tobacco period.
You know,
they don't use chemicals to grow their tobacco.
They do it like that.
Would you smoke?
That's what I used to smoke when you would say like,
ah,
I'm quitting cigarettes,
you know I'm going to smoke natural spirits instead.
You do smoke less cause they're so strong.
Yeah.
But the problem I had with it was that after some Megan knows,
I felt like I was just coughing up black shit like it.
Yeah.
It was just like the 599 chemicals to keep you alive.
They diluted,
you know,
looks,
if you were smart and you were owning a cigarette company,
you would want to create cigarettes to keep these fucks alive,
right?
You know,
so some shit that they need,
they're addicted to it.
We've got a two problems we want to keep alive,
right?
But we want them addicted as fuck.
What can we do?
This is what we got,
and I got this thing right here.
This is going to preserve them.
This additive is going to kill the cancer.
This additive is going to rebuild the tissue surrounding it,
okay?
I'll look at Alicia.
This ad,
it was going to make
it stronger.
It's going to make it bigger.
Nicotine rush,
Edgar detective,
bigger Dick Filters,
bigger dick filters if you just called it bigger de filters,
right?
Those extends tablets that they sell.
You know those those tablets or you know,
they have them at the gas station over here,
right?
You got to get gas and right in front of you is like,
do you want your Dick Bigger?
That's what it is.
I can fucking still look.
They don't do anything.
It doesn't do anything.
It's like tribulus and a bunch of other stupid shit,
but it doesn't make your Dick Bigger.
There's not a Goddamn pilled that makes your Dick Bigger.
Makes your eyes smaller.
Oh,
Brian.
Brian,
So a California,
um,
the deadline is the 18th,
which is a what is today?
So six days from today,
the deadline is next Monday for a registering to vote in California is going to
be,
they're going to the number one thing for,
you know,
a lot of people is the legalization of marijuana.
Yeah.
And you could actually registered online to vote for it.
Uh,
let me see if I can find a website.
Um,
so you don't even have to leave your house if you need to register.
Is that,
and this crazy.
Meg Whitman and what's his name?
Brown.
What the Hell's his name?
Jerry Brown.
Ebay versus,
what is his name?
Jerry Brown.
Yeah.
You don't even get this fly on go.
You don't even pretend to give a fuck about politics,
which is hilarious.
Yeah.
You can just feel like an adult do.
Do you ever feel like an adult?
No.
I like being as young as possible.
But what happens when you're 50 that's great.
And you still took like that?
That'd be awesome.
Yeah.
Jerry Brown was running for president back back in weighing the,
in the does a back when I was a young lad.
Hmm.
And now,
and he was at one point in time,
I believe he was governor of California.
Hmm.
And now he is,
uh,
trying to be governor again,
but he's an interesting dude.
He's a fucking strange guy
to the website to go to is www dot s o s.
Dot.
C A.
G O v Backslash or stop that.
No one's going to remember that shit.
You asshole people trying to,
scrambling to write that shit down.
We'll Google it.
What are we googling to register to vote online for a prop 19?
Yeah,
just figure it out,
man.
You can figure it out.
But,
but do it by Monday if you're in California because you have to vote.
Uh,
you got to do two things.
One.
You've got to vote for Jerry Brown because you don't want this crazy meg Whitman
broad being the governor of California all at all.
I mean some salty language in the race phones,
California governor.
It's difficult to hear,
but it's a voicemail recording.
That was really funny.
Jerry Brown.
Meg Whitman was called a whore clans.
Jerry Brown phone message.
Wow.
Laddering word to describe Republican megabit.
Here.
We can hear you.
[inaudible]
what an
insult to the women of California and insulted the Women in
California.
No,
it's an insult to you.
You fucking whore.
How ridiculous.
An insult to the women of California and that called her a whore.
It's ridiculous.
How can she stand up for all the women in California?
Because that's what kind of powers.
Yeah.
I can't vote for you just based on that alone.
On that alone.
I can see that you're crazy.
That is not an insult to the women of California.
You're silly that someone called you a whore did cause they think you have very
Horlick instincts and this Jerry Brown character,
I'm pretty sure he smokes weed.
Yeah,
I'm looking at him.
I don't think he swung suede.
I'm not sure.
It's just guesswork is California.
So that's the only thing I should look at.
Do vote on for whatever the fuck you want.
But I'm voting for Jerry Brown and I'm voting yes on the weed thing.
Are you really going to routine?
Fuck yeah,
I'm voting on this.
You've added,
yes,
of course I have.
I think state voting is probably pretty real.
You know,
I think when you start voting,
you know,
voting for president and that's when the mad crazy corruption is in place,
you know?
But I think you could really get things changed in states.
I mean even bad things like the gay marriage thing,
you know,
they,
they really did get it.
So the gay people couldn't get married anymore.
I mean they really,
they did it.
They organize,
they put it together and they,
they fixed it.
They changed it in their opinion.
You know,
you can get things done.
Like marijuana's legal basically in California already.
Medicus decriminalized at the other day.
That's awesome.
Decriminalize it.
And because it's on the road to to being legal.
It should have been legal a long time ago.
We don't have to get over this story again.
Uh,
go over the story gala.
It's a ridiculous law that doesn't,
it doesn't make any sense in anybody's fighting against it.
Like Meg Whitman is meg Whitman broad things that they should shut down all
these medical marijuana dispensary.
Exactly.
So I got to vote for you or against you on that too.
You crazy shit.
One of his girls like who brought that check to the party?
Well,
she's really rich too.
She had something to do with Ebay,
right?
Yes.
She so she got that paper and she just want to be running shit.
She got that paper and she was like,
I'm going to fix the world from my babies.
She's just going to go out there.
She's going to,
we don't need medical marijuana.
We need hugs in Jesus.
How much money do you have?
High have our billion dollars.
The most important thing though is if California passes,
it's medical marijuana law.
Excuse me,
the legalization of marijuana,
if they pass it,
what's going to happen is you're going to be able to get pot everywhere in
California.
It's going to be something where you can get it responsible adults over 21 just
like drinking,
just like it should be anything else.
You know,
once you become an adult and you can take responsibility for your own self,
we hope that you were raised enough so that you can,
you know well enough rather so you can understand what happens when you have too
many beers or too much to drink and you know,
we hope you fucking conduct yourself in a gentlemanly fashion.
You know,
keep your shit together.
You should be able to do that with pot too.
Yeah,
there's going to be problems.
It's going to be problems with everything.
There's problems with Starbucks.
I drive by Starbucks.
I go,
damn,
I go for coffee right now.
I don't even want a coffee.
I'm not tired.
There's nothing wrong with me.
But that Shit's addictive.
It's delicious.
I'm going to debt that Burt's deep like hot liquid and you pour the cream in it
and ah,
no it Tate said best Tait Fletcher.
He goes,
why I get a coffee?
It's like ugh.
And now he does like it's a hug in a cup.
He used to drink fucking four vintages a day.
I do take,
did not fuck around.
He did some serious training too.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why he's body was able to take that giant jolt of
caffeine every day.
Who's in such awesome shape?
What is this shit that gene Simmons out wants to sue all at MP3 downloaders
yeah.
Gene Simmons is apparently,
I'm saying that all people that steal music online,
he wants to sue them all and go after them all and that's doesn't his son go,
Hey dad,
dad,
dad come here.
His son [inaudible] his son has the ability to talk to him.
I mean,
I wouldn't let my son tell me what I can and can't say.
If I made a billion dollar empire out of music,
I would say,
I know what the fuck I'm doing,
dude,
just relax.
This is part of my character,
part of my characters and I'm a business span asshole and then I go after
people.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean he's always been like that.
I mean [inaudible] I think they have been selling kiss merchandise from the get
go back when no bands were doing it.
They had kiss army and you get into the kiss army and you fucking,
I was in the kiss army dude,
I had a kiss army tee shirt and shit and you get a sticker and a patch and shit
and you become part of the kiss army.
You know,
he's just been a one of those guys.
It's always been very business minded,
which is kind of rare for artists.
Right.
So I understand where all these guys are coming from.
I understood where the Metallica Dude,
Lars Earl rich,
I understood where he was coming from.
He's saying people are stealing,
people are stealing when people are staying on.
Yes,
but here's the problem.
Yeah it is.
Technically they shouldn't be able to do it,
but they can.
So they will and it's that simple.
They can.
So they will,
and it's your job.
All you can do is put out great music and if you cannot be legally protected,
like in a certain sense of the Internet,
I don't think you can.
They're going to go after a few people here and there and they're going to sue
them.
But people are always going to download your shit.
Just form a relationship between the artists and the fans.
Former relationship with these people.
Appreciate you.
And if they enjoy your shit,
they,
they'll go and buy it.
They'll go and buy it once they download.
I have a lot of friends who will download either a movie or a or songs and
always not just by the CACD on iTunes,
but tell everybody they bought the CD because I,
they'll say like,
I downloaded it,
dude.
It was so good.
I went out and I bought it on iTunes.
I'm telling everybody,
go buy this.
It's the Shit,
you know?
It's like you get more fans.
It's just going to expose more people to your shit.
Yeah,
it's gonna fuck up record stores,
but they're already dead.
You know,
tower records is dead.
There's a place right down here.
I used to drive and I used to go,
there's a CD store.
That shit is going to be like,
like we're talking about like buffalo skinning factories.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's gone.
There's no CD stores used to be able to go.
Like there was a giant store.
You would walk through the rock section.
Oh look at this.
They got juniors previous greatest heads,
you know,
and you would go through this store that had all these physical cds in him.
That's,
that's dinosaur shit.
Yeah.
The only thing I think there's money for is used CD stores.
You know,
cause I,
I still go into USC and he stores,
I'll buy like $10 worth.
They use cds.
Listen man,
it killed it.
Yeah.
Mean the downloading on the Internet killed those CD stores.
But guess what?
They were going to die anyway.
They were going to die anyway because the Internet,
they have to die there.
They're silly when I can have everything in your fucking store on my phone.
Okay.
You have a store,
you have a giant store.
Everything in your stores on my phone.
You need to quit what you're doing because you're doing something stupid.
That's a dumb way to do it.
You a giant store where it's all fucking inboxes and these little plastic crates
and like this will waste.
This is all wasteful stuff.
It's must go to the clouds.
It's crazy.
I'd like,
there's a lot of things are going fucking digital or like Google TV.
He,
you know when people are like,
you know like it's like that's the argument that you know in,
in Gene Simmons said this too,
that it crushed the music business because they were asleep at the wheel and
then the digital,
I don't think it crushed them because they were sleeping at the wheel.
It crushed him because they were irrelevant.
Right.
They didn't,
they didn't need to sell it like that anymore.
It was too,
it's too readily available to easy to access to,
easy to get.
So now it becomes more artists based and more becomes more about seeing live
performances and supporting the artists by buying merchandise and shit like
that.
It becomes more of like that like and making it a legal avenue that's very
convenient.
Like the iTunes store.
I buy all my shit on the iTunes store cause it's super easy.
It's very rare I ever have to look anywhere else to find some songs in the best
is when you're driving down the street,
just open up iTunes while you're driving,
you search do that,
you fall,
you could totally do it and then you just find the song you want and download it
while you're driving and automatically play it within 30 seconds.
Yeah,
that's pretty fascinating.
It's pretty fascinating that this is all happening inside our lifetime,
you know?
So the,
the,
the iTunes,
the way they got it.
I like it because it's nice and easy and you know,
you don't have to go searching,
you know,
I'm like,
it's right there.
What I want,
James Brown,
ch Bam or what?
I don't even know what he's on there.
I'm sure he is right.
Probably.
Anyway,
the point is that as long as it's,
if people can,
they'll,
they'll always support the artists,
man.
You gotta you gotta you gotta appreciate that.
The only reason why you're able to do all this as,
because people enjoy what you do.
And yeah,
there's going to be some people that get your shit.
But that's just because that's what technology is all about today.
It's all about easy access to information and music is basically just
information.
It's just ones and Zeros.
You can't stop that shit but you can damage the way people like look at you and
like you don't appreciate,
you know the fact that sometimes people don't have money.
You don't appreciate the fact that you know there's going to be people that
need,
you know,
to support their families and they need to like spend money on important shit
and they really don't.
They can't really make room for another 12 bucks for your fucking CD,
you know?
So they just download it for free but they still love you and then like a year
later they come see you in concert.
Like it all balances out I think.
I think so too.
I mean,
I don't know.
I'm not a fucking tower records executive.
Cause if you were at tower records executive or Warner brothers or any of these
big labels that got fucking crushed by all this,
uh,
this MP3 business,
I mean,
what do they do now?
How do they,
how are they even making money?
You know,
mostly iTunes muscly and selling it to TV shows and movies and commercials.
And I think the,
instead of selling it in w two a record,
you're now selling it to all these other things,
you know?
I know.
That's why I don't understand like how much money cds and records east to make.
Because back then they weren't selling it at,
you know,
like fucking,
you didn't watch all in the family and then have,
you know,
the black eyed peas playing in the background,
so things like that,
you know,
iTunes and it seems like they're,
they're everywhere.
So you think licensing is where they're making their,
I think that's has to be where they're making their money.
You know,
I mean there,
there licensing,
fucking ringtones there.
Lysing singing music and video games and movies and fucking commercials.
It just seems like all that shit didn't exist back in the 70s when,
when supposedly that,
that,
but back then there was zero piracy back when there was vinyl albums.
That's what you get.
You've got a vinyl album.
Have,
you know,
you could,
there's no piracy find going to do well in 1980 there was,
I'm not sure actually.
But even then,
what do you mean 1980 [inaudible] when fucking a cassette tape came out,
when was so sure.
But it was never as good.
Didn't sound as good.
Dual cassette.
It made it pretty good copy if you've got a good Maxwell in there.
Yeah.
Cause that's like the second concept.
The concept was good.
Yeah it was.
You do that all the time.
And the cassettes that they sound really good,
like good quality stereo I think pretty much as good as the it copied as good as
it was.
If he bought a quality cassette,
did a cassette ever sounds good as a CD or CD is better.
Oh,
cities way better sound quality and yeah,
so there was album was number one,
cassette was number two,
but CD is not as good as album.
Right.
So the people say,
yeah,
there's like an analog quality to s to music.
Yeah,
I guess there's like whatever deeper sounds stuff,
but you also don't have
every 30 seconds,
you know?
Sometimes I liked that man.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
totally.
Sometimes I like that,
you know,
like the hisses and pumps and shit.
You know,
there's something cool about old music if you listen through headphones.
But absolutely.
I don't have the patience to be sitting there with headphones on while a record
spins around the needle on it.
I don't have that kind of patients,
you know?
I'm not that into music.
Fucking changing those needles with a pain in the ass to remember that shit.
You had to advise a new needle.
Barely.
Man,
I barely remember it,
but I do remember being a kid being absolutely fucking fascinating to do here to
somehow or another get all this music into this desk.
I thought it was like magic to me.
You know,
lines.
Yeah.
I,
this left one day they left me alone and I had a stack of their records.
My parents was just leave me alone.
I'll be like eight.
And they would just go places.
That's cool.
No it's not cool.
I gotta been sticking knives into electrical sockets and shit,
but I was fucking around with their record player and I remember just being
absolutely
fascinating.
I was doing a bunch of shit I shouldn't have been doing like going backwards and
forwards with it and fucking with the needle I'm sure.
But um,
I was just thinking how insane it is that somehow or another this needle
interacts with this surface and it brings this incredibly rich music out of,
out of this black plastic thing.
Like how did that come about?
That is some alien shit right there.
That is nuts.
That somehow or another,
they figured this out a long time ago.
Like in the 19.
What does it like forties like when did they have CD or a record of vinyl?
Long time ago.
Yeah.
Used to be on the wet middle plates or something like that in the old days or
was it a real ever on wax or is,
what does that mean by put it down on wax?
Doesn't that mean like the,
yeah.
Well I think the record's considered where
maybe,
yeah,
I don't know how the fuck they did it,
but it's pretty amazing.
You know,
it's almost more amazing to me than,
than what we can do today because we do so much other cool shit today.
You know,
there's so many things you could do today,
but like,
you know,
cell phone messaging and you know,
fit watching youtube videos on your phone,
there's all sorts of fascinating shit you could do today.
So the idea of storing music on some piece of plastic doesn't seem insane at
all.
But God damn back in the forties I must've been the craziest thing ever.
Like there was nothing like that.
Like there's a ghost inside this disk and you just rub a,
a pointed piece of metal on it and it lifts up and comes through the speakers
and it's incredible.
And I don't like whole lot of love and just a needle scratching on a piece of
plastic in this small ones had to be played at a different speed for some
reason,
which made no sense to me.
How different would life be if we didn't have that?
How different would life be if there was no music?
If they never figured out a way to record music,
which if you and I were alive back then,
they never would have figured out a way to record music.
Right.
You'll just have that one friend that was really good at singing that you would
invite to at parties if you like.
Really for real,
it feels like if like you and I were responsible for coming up with a way to
record music,
it would never happen.
No,
it would never take place.
There has to be like a gigantic evolution of people who are science minded and
understand technology and recording sounds and they have to put it together and
it just figure out a way to get it onto this piece of plastic and make it sound
realistic.
And they did all this shit before they were internet,
but before there was the internet,
before there was like cell phones before anything,
the computers were gigantic computers.
It would fill up entire rooms,
you know,
that was the computers they had in the fifties what they have,
it's just really like buildings was a computer.
Yeah,
I mean the,
and it's nothing compared to your iPhone doesn't even have nearly the processing
power that your iPhone has.
And back then they figured out how to put music down in these plastic discs is
crazy.
Guys.
If they'd ever figured it out,
man,
what?
Life would be so strange.
We would always have music.
But if you had no music in your car,
you went,
no music and movies.
Just have to have a friend come with you in the car.
Yeah.
What if there was no way to record music?
There's no way to actually record sounds.
What would
have King Kong for clouds and they were both in outer space and neither one had
a speed advantage cause there were weightless.
We might have smoked too much pot before we did this podcast.
That's what it's going to be.
My new song.
Well I'm going to play that back and we're going to take that as a chunk.
That will be a little blip that going to use whenever we get on one of those
little strange conversations.
It doesn't seem like it's going anywhere.
Just play that we might have smoked too much pot before we did this podcast.
Definitely smoked too much pot today.
Uh,
yes you have Brian.
That's why I'm out here.
Uh,
so trying to explain to you about Meg Whitman said,
I've been doing a lot of standup lately and I know you have been,
one of the hardest things I've keep on catching myself doing is doing the cheesy
one liners that sound like Jaylin and or the next day like know the next day
I'll read it and be like,
ah,
it's so Jay Leno really like what my light like.
Hey,
my name's Brian and I do stand up comedy when I'm single.
So ladies,
if you don't like my comedy date me,
I didn't tell him,
hey,
I now know how much of,
what are you willing to explain,
um,
that you're,
you're getting out of a relationship and that like,
I'm doing comedy is a new way to spend your social time.
Oh,
it's awesome.
Like at first,
you know,
getting on a relationship you have nothing to do,
you're lonely.
You were like devastated.
Like let's,
without going into details for folks who don't know,
my buddy Brian.
Okay.
It was a crazy hot and heavy and then gone right and on a whirlwind fashion.
Yeah.
It was literally a head fuck.
Definitely.
No,
I mean it was a head fuck to the point that your list,
like I give up,
this is ridiculous.
And then it got to the point where I was just at home all the time and then I
was like,
all right,
I have to get out of this fucking house.
So I started going on like binge drinking,
you know,
for like,
like a week.
And I was like right,
that's binge or Bangerz Bettinger drinking,
whatever that means.
That sounds we want to binge drinking.
Yeah.
So you went on vendors,
vendors,
you got fucked up every day and then on every day and getting drunk.
No,
for like five days I did it straight go.
God,
I just went,
not because I didn't have anything to do.
So then I was like,
all right,
this can't continue it cause that's,
that's,
that'll kill you.
I can gross.
And so I started doing stand up comedy and then immediately you get put in the
standup comedy road,
you realize,
all right,
there's a bunch of people that were on the same team as you,
all at the same level as you.
And everywhere you go there at the same mix as you and stuff,
immediately you just become like groups with these people.
It's pretty awesome.
So you just found a bunch of friends.
I'm trying to punch your freelance.
So um,
it's so it started out as like a social thing,
like yeah,
go out and do something.
Fucking let out my anger on stage and meet some people to be,
are you telling jokes about her?
I have one joke and it's not even finished yet.
It was just that a,
yeah,
my girl,
my ex girlfriend has a fake vagina and crazy cause on the box.
This is,
you know,
ultra realistic,
which is bullshit because fake vaginas don't have mom issues or HIV scares.
Brian's just start now folks,
you know,
like comedies off for everybody.
That's what I'm saying.
It turns into that Jaylen job,
it turns into j Lo,
listen,
you've got to learn how to beat yourself up there.
That's the hardest part.
The hardest part of comedy is learning how to relax and you get these crazy
spots where it's like,
it's much more difficult because you get like five minutes spots or 10 minutes
spots like right.
Yeah.
That's like ready go.
Like you don't know,
you have all these ideas that you maybe want to talk about.
Maybe I should do this bit.
No,
I'm gonna try this one.
You,
none of them are totally proven to you.
It's very tricky.
You know,
I did Molly the other day and I think it really opened up this whole thing on
stage for me though because I was having a hard time being on stage,
being myself.
Like,
like how I just did that joke.
It's not how I say it to Molly.
Is that what you said?
Yeah.
Molly,
it's what does your model is here?
Uh,
ecstasy.
Oh,
well we expect us to know that you fucking junkie.
You don't know this club shit.
He just goes,
what did all of the other day all like casual and shit.
And I was like,
do I need to stop this and find out what Molly is like?
Yes I do.
He's not going to explain it.
What the fuck is Molly that I told you that?
Well,
even if you did tell me,
we're doing a podcast right now,
fellow,
and there's a lot of people listening.
So that's Molly.
Molly is pure ecstasy.
It's called like MD empty.
This is stuff you go from that Russian scientist and scientists.
A chick with the red hair was really long legs,
hot shot.
Don't get the details,
man.
Give her up.
She was like,
do you want it?
Okay.
So the Russian scientists gives you this stuff called Molly.
Yeah.
And uh,
and I'm like,
well what is it?
Ecstasy?
And she goes,
well,
no,
it's just pure ecstasy.
It has no idea of their chemicals.
It's just,
you said,
is it Exede?
She said,
no,
it's pure ecstasy.
Well,
she meaning it's not like the typical ecstasy.
You buy it like a club or you,
you,
you know,
get off a gentleman and behind seven 11.
So that stuff's like,
got like meth in it.
Yeah.
It hasn't like straight nine usually.
And crazy shit in it like that.
Why?
I mean,
it's bad for you.
Supposedly this is actually good for you.
Not really.
But what it does though is it comes in a capsule form and there's like a powder
in it by the way.
We don't just don't do this shit,
but don't listen to him.
Yeah.
So the rest of the chick was like,
Hey,
uh,
you know,
do you want to do it?
And I'm like,
you know,
I'm kind of scared.
You know,
I'll just take a little,
so she just took open the capsule and put a little in my drink and I drank it.
And then like within like 30 minutes,
it felt like every single pour of my body was vibrating.
It felt like when you're half asleep,
you know when you're in that first rem sleep or whatever it is,
what you'd like your body,
your mind's awake,
but your body's not.
So I would've felt like,
but I was being able to walk,
I was being able to talk and I,
it wasn't like the ecstasy,
like where you're just like,
ah,
you know,
like kind of out of it.
This was just like pure fucking orgasms.
It was amazing.
So anyways,
after that,
a couple of days after I went back on stage and I felt this weird groove when on
stage of that I always just like,
hey,
you know,
hey like really relaxed.
Like I,
it's kind of like still kind of feeling kind of like a looseness or uh,
a comfortability and it was weird cause ever since then totally how I so
something
comfortable from the ecstasy experience that it was so loving and loose and fun.
Maybe more loving and loose.
I guess for some reason on stage.
Well relaxed you,
it puts you all in perspective too.
It makes you understand what,
what ecstasy did for me.
I only did it once and I don't know what was in it cause I was jack the next
day.
Dude I was jacked the next day.
I felt really bad.
Like I felt really dumb.
See I didn't have that there wasn't hip.
That's one of the good things about that cause it's pure,
you don't have that.
Then the next day shit I got woke up fine as fuck and I went to bed easy as
hell.
Yeah.
I don't know what was in the thing.
I mean,
I know there was definitely some ecstasy in it,
but what I got out of it when I was,
when the experience was happening was that so much of the way we interact with
each other is based on insecurity.
And when no one has insecurities,
you know,
and everyone's just hanging out.
Like it's like people can be so much more friendly to each other,
so much more loving to each other and so much fun.
I mean it sounds so hippy faggy bullshit,
but you know,
I was like,
wow.
Like could you imagine if this state could be recreated all the time?
I was like,
look at,
look at the way we're interacting.
Like now,
like this is a really like the best way you could ever enjoy a bunch of people's
company.
But if we were like this all the time,
nothing would get done.
You know,
you would have no reason you would,
would you just need enough food to stay alive?
Right.
And we'd be living like Indians out there and tents and shit.
And I could see myself getting addicted to that drug.
And how was the first time where,
I mean,
I don't know if I could do it every day,
but it felt so good that I want to do it again where most drugs I'm like,
ah,
that was good.
You know?
Yeah.
It feels like you're going to hold people's hands and shit.
Like you don't even know why.
Give people a hug and it's just like radiates.
It's very strange,
you know,
why,
why does that exist in our brains?
You know?
I mean,
basically what we're doing is we're,
we're hijacking our reward system,
right?
And we were injecting,
you know,
all these,
uh,
new chemical rewards into our whole system that our brain has to process it and
it's not making any of its own.
And while this is processing it,
and then after it's over,
that's why you have like this drop off,
you know?
And the next day they tell you,
you're supposed to take things to try to re stimulate your brain's production of
chemicals.
You know,
dopamine or Serotonin,
whatever the fuck it is.
Right.
But you,
you know,
you,
you experienced a drop off after the big flood and the drop off from me the next
day,
whatever it was,
whether it was because of the crystal meth in it or who the fuck knows what was
really in black tar heroin.
But the drop off was too much from Amen.
It was just,
it was too crazy.
I was too dumb.
The next day I was like,
this is like brain damage,
Tom.
Like,
imagine if I had to go through the rest of my life being this dumb.
This is like a lot of people do.
You know,
a lot of people go through the rest of their life,
you know,
just,
they're just not there anymore.
That's fucked up.
Yeah.
You get hit in the head with a fucking fastball.
Things happen.
All of a sudden.
You're not the same.
Right.
You could have been smoking meth the whole time.
Well,
you know,
I knew the dude who had it had this stuff and they had done it a bunch of times
and so I knew it was wasn't going to kill me,
but I didn't really know.
Solid.
Got busted out of fucking Ph kit and started testing it with saliva.
Let's see what we've got here.
Do you think you'll ever do that again or any kind of magic mushrooms?
Yes,
definitely.
Yeah.
I've,
I've done them certain recently,
but um,
yeah,
but the,
the um,
Mtma is too much.
Oh,
I don't know.
Then the next day is too hard.
I'm so freaked out about mushrooms now and like I'm more afraid mushrooms then
that just from like molds and stuff like that.
It's illegal,
man.
That's all it is.
If it was legal,
it would be so easy to control and grow.
Right.
So fucking easy.
And all they have to do is you have all these pain management centers that you
have set up all throughout Florida that they have these oxycontin problems,
you know,
I mean,
we have chiropractors everywhere.
We have all sorts of people that deal with all sorts of different,
various health issues in it.
And even in the Chiropractic,
a sense a lot of people think that's quackery.
A lot of people don't even Glengary they did.
They don't even believe it.
You never heard that word.
Never.
It's a really common word.
They,
they believed,
they don't even believe in Chiropractic.
Well,
another thing that is,
you know,
that different cultures have used to try to heal people,
try to get people straight for thousands of years.
It's psychedelics.
You can't say that all these cultures that have used this thing like,
oh,
they used,
um,
uh,
you know,
acupressure or these acupuncture or they used,
the various tantric methods.
Okay.
You can practice all of these.
All these are all ancient things that people find relief from stress.
And I see,
I see,
I see.
Well,
we also use these mushrooms.
Nope.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
Oh,
well no,
they're okay.
We've been using it for 10,000 years.
No,
no,
no.
Don't bring them in.
I mean,
it's like they'll stop at a certain thing,
you know,
they'll go through all these other different things that you're allowed to do
that ancient people have done and you can practice all these shamonic rituals as
long as you're just blowing tobacco smoke in the air and chanting like a retard
without the IOWASCA.
When you add the Iowasca,
then things get strange.
Then they want to lock you in a cage for doing something that people have found
relief with for thousands of years.
If mushrooms were legal,
they would sell them all over the place and people in the community would set up
shamonic centers.
They would set up centers where people who have already had these experiences
can talk you through it and help you out and even go with you on the first time
you do it.
So you'll take like,
you know,
they'll start you off slow.
We're going to take one gram today and this is what a one gram experience is
like.
And then just does the guy who's done it for fucking a thousand times and he
knows what he's doing and he'll,
you know,
they can make sure they're not creepy.
Then I tried to date rape anybody I need just set up these centers because that
does happen.
Even in the Shamana community as a lot of dudes are just in it for posing right
now.
They want to be thought of as like the main wise man and they tried to bang on
these checks.
It's really tripping.
It's kind of funny cause even inside this,
you know whole psychedelic community,
there's a bunch of people that are still kind of like lost halfway pretending
they're halfway that guy.
But there are also halfway full of shit because they're really just trying to
get laid and and come off like some like enlightened guy.
But if they set that up,
man,
if it was legal,
if that's the next step,
if this marijuana thing passes and then next thing let's go after mushrooms man.
Because mushrooms have only helped everybody that I know.
The only problem with mushrooms is that actually takes you out,
take you out now that you're not going to be driving a half on mushrooms.
You Know Eddie Bravo did that.
He did the needle of this story.
Yeah,
us.
So crazy.
I don't know if he wants this.
Tell,
told total,
um,
let's say this is what he heard from somebody else.
Okay.
It's not really ready to buy now.
I can,
yes.
I'm just,
I'm going to tell you a different story now.
So this,
he goes to the zoo.
Okay.
They take five grams a month rooms and they got five grams is what Terence
Mckenna would call a heroic dose.
That's a line from a bill Hicks,
a CD,
but it's also a Terence Mckenna really called it.
He called it a heroic dose and anything about five grams because you just
dissolve,
you don't exist anymore.
When you hit that apex at five grams,
you become a part of some fucking much larger mosaic.
It's like [inaudible].
There's like this incredible amount of artwork that you see,
incredible amount of visuals that connectivity,
the,
the communication.
It's like you feel like you're communicating with like some super ultra
intelligent life form that's explaining everything and it all makes sense.
I mean it is a fucking mind blower of an experience.
So he takes this five grams,
this is what five grams does to you.
And he goes to the zoo.
I mean it's like classic like that.
Bill Hicks had a joke about doing that,
about going to a fucking amusing park.
So he goes to the fucking zoo and gets super depressed.
I would to like,
he's like the negative energy.
So it was overwhelming because they get all these monkeys,
man,
that can think and they're all in these cages.
I went to one in Colorado with this monkey was screaming like a mental patient,
like screaming,
like in agony.
He was in a small cage and it was a corner cage.
So it was around this Ben.
So everybody just walked in front of his cage back and forth,
back and forth,
and he was like,
it was dark dude.
It was dark.
I was like,
you cannot make any argument for keeping monkeys and cages after this guy.
That guy's being tortured.
This is an intelligent little animal stuck by itself in a metal box and he's
been stared at all day by bigger monkeys and he's freaking the fuck out.
So any is tripping out.
He's,
he's in a five gram full blown trip feeling just waves of negative energy,
you know,
just splashing into them constantly.
Every time he goes by all these different animal cages and sees them the reality
of their miserable existence there.
So he's like,
we gotta get the fuck out of here.
So he takes his girlfriend and they get in the car and start driving.
And as he's driving,
it's a full blown mushroom trip.
He said the,
the ground in front of his car became pedals of roses,
rose laterals.
And it was like everywhere.
They were splashing all up and around the car.
He said the entire,
he was on the highway.
He went on the highway,
son.
He had a,
I think he got off of what?
I lost you all together eventually,
but he was driving on the fucking
on,
on the highway and seem like rose petals in front of his car has not cool man.
It's really not glow.
He's lucky or she,
whoever that person's talking about,
you're talking over this guy is,
we're saying Russian lady.
Yeah,
man.
It was,
it was a dark moment in his,
in his existence.
I've driven,
the first time I tripped on acid,
I drove,
uh,
on the way home,
but it was like eight,
six hours after I dosed.
And so I wasn't really still though,
but I was having sex at the same time.
I think I talked about this on one of the earlier podcasts I went to go see.
Tell you that happened.
Well,
I went to on acid having sex and driving.
why aren't you doing nirvana concert met Kurt Cobain.
He'd gave me Cheetos,
cursing God at the same time.
No,
no,
I remember it was,
I had a big station wagon with one of the wood on the thing we had to drive back
to Columbus to show is in Dayton.
And so your dosed up with us.
Right?
So with your girl driving and she starts rubbing me or doing something like
that.
Dirty Bitch.
She climbs on me.
Oh my God.
The back of the car and I'm facing the front of the cool.
That's real good for your peripheral vision on the right side.
Yeah.
Can you see pastor hair?
I don't.
Yeah.
Someone's trying to change.
She was a very tiny girl.
Very tiny.
Very tiny girls.
She was eight.
No,
no,
no.
I mean she was just a small girl.
She's a woman.
Yes.
Let's say woman's model.
How old was she?
Uh,
I think we were about 17.
So she was a girl.
Sure.
How old were you?
17.
Okay.
So yeah,
she was in my class.
Who's letting you drive at 17?
Uh,
on assay.
I know where the girl on top of you.
You crazy.
Crazy.
And then what was so crazy?
I was like,
the sex got really good.
So then we decided to pull off into a church parking lot off the side of the
highway and finish it at the parking lot.
Take up busted in a church parking lot.
Who?
Tate.
Oh,
that's right.
I remember that.
My friends got budget.
Maybe we should sue told until the story who,
who got busted smoking pot in the church parking lot of friends from high school
and there were 17 used to always go to the uh,
this church to smoke pie and they got arrested and had to do community service
and it was like some crazy,
like 60 hours of community service at the Columbus just for smoking pot at the
Columbus Zoo and their job was shoveling shit.
Wow.
That's a fascinating thing man.
It's fascinating that people can force you to do things because you got caught
doing something that you wanted to do.
So all you do want to do that and we say you can't do that.
So now you have to do this community service for smoking weed is the most
ridiculous thing ever.
If you give someone community service for smoking weed for sure.
You need to smoke weed for sure.
Totally.
That should be your reward.
You know you should.
Okay,
I'll do the community service,
but you have to smoke some pot too now.
Don't you feel bad?
You smoke the pot.
Yeah.
How do you feel about me and this orange jumpsuit picking up garbage.
You fucking douchebag.
If you ever had to just cause I wanted to get high.
No,
I've never been arrested Brian.
I'm an outstanding citizen.
My taxes.
No,
that seems so crazy to me.
Why?
I don't know.
I keep it together.
You've been a good boy.
I've keep it together.
I'm very good at keeping it together and that's great.
It's very hard.
I have crazy instincts.
My instincts aren't so good.
My instincts are so good.
My bike,
my brain,
the very last line goes down.
No,
no,
no.
This is gonna put you in jail.
Don't do anything stupid.
Yeah.
Well I think if I tape it really close to my body,
I can get through the customs.
Right.
Ralphie May,
I ended up on getting a hundred dollars ticket,
by the way from that Guam.
And that was actually an accident.
Yeah.
Ralph,
he told Joe he could've been fucked.
If you don't know what this is,
we're talking about Ralphie mega bus with pot,
but he could get like,
you know,
some countries you have like a marijuana seed and you're in prison for eight
years in Guam is America.
Oh it is.
I'm going to wake Guam isn't,
I don't think it's America,
but I think it's like so closely related.
Standby.
Puerto Rico's America.
I don't know where Guam is.
I think it's more Pacific.
I think it's more near,
um,
I think Puerto Rico is the Atlantic side,
right?
Because that's where so many Puerto Rican,
east coast.
Yes.
It's below Florida's.
Yeah.
And Guam or other,
yeah,
I think qualm is near Hawaii.
I think it's on the way to Hawaii.
Oh,
on the way.
Like from the other side.
Cool.
No,
I think it's near Hawaii.
I'm pretty sure.
But I think it's like it's the whole idea that Hawaii and you know Puerto Rico
that then could somehow under,
there'd be a part of the United States that's so silly.
Like you're way over there.
Like how do we fit in?
Well I do understand that we must take over as many countries as possible so we
can destroy everybody.
You know,
kind of thing.
Like we have Alaska way over here just as a retreat just in case of the country
believes that we're all going to allow it.
That's why they got Alaska.
You don't even know your history son.
Doesn't it seem like they would do that?
Like they have to keep us protected from the Soviet Union?
I don't know.
This isn't that one.
Sarah Palin,
he used to say that she could see Alaska,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
I don't think that's why they got Alaska,
Brian.
No,
no,
don't think so.
I learn I'd be buying all this shit.
You can't buy countries anymore.
Do they stopped doing that?
You know that North America used to be under a one sheet of ice that was a mile
high.
That covered like half the country just 10,000 years ago.
Really?
10,000 fucking years ago,
10,000 years ago,
North America half covered a nice,
that's crazy.
Woolly mammoths and fucking saber tooth tigers running around.
They had,
they all died.
They all died off.
They don't know why.
I've been watching all these documentaries on meteor impacts.
Food is without a doubt the scariest thing that could happen at any second
anytime.
They literally have no idea how many are up there.
They have no idea which ones are coming towards us.
Every now and then somebody spots one.
It's usually amateurs who's amateur.
Astronomers are just staring at the sky all night and they'll notice there's
like a light in the sky that wasn't there before.
And then they'll notice it again.
Like,
you know,
they take photos of it and they'll take a photo with the next day and I go,
okay,
this is moving and it's moving in this direction.
And the contact someone and they start tracking this thing.
What's the coordinates in the sky?
Oh Shit,
this is a fucking asteroid.
You know?
And that's how we find a lot of them.
There's like hundreds of thousands of near Earth objects between Mars and
Jupiter and every now and then when one of them will collide with another one
and it'll just go rocketing towards earth,
45,000 miles an hour.
Some of them are just solid iron and they were like a mile wide shot.
Thank you for being generous dude.
Do you have any idea how fucking crazy that would be if we were all standing
outside and all of a sudden you could see in the distance the fireball that was
going to kill you in three days?
Could you imagine?
You could see it coming.
You see it rounding?
Yeah.
Mars.
You definitely get your way.
You're going to just start fucking I crazy.
What would you I think I would just start crying.
I didn't think you'd fuck like just start fucking like crazy.
I think everyone would just go crazy orgy mode because I know I've talked about
this with many people before.
What would you do?
And it was just like,
like if you saw it as like an asteroid,
he had like one hour,
what do you do?
You start fucking,
he started going like,
all right,
it's time to do the anal.
Everybody says [inaudible] you going to be the catcher?
No,
no,
no.
I mean to the girl,
like,
all right,
you can finally do it.
I guess I'm,
I'm not gonna feel anything later.
He said,
wow,
you'd want to fuck her in the ass and her life.
No,
but I'm saying everyone has that,
that same thing.
I think the last moments of her life and you want it to be all you take it.
No,
I'm just saying though,
everyone says that they would go fucking,
if there was like one hour left you,
you think of to turn in this huge ball of bodies on the streets and everyone
says,
gee is everywhere.
It just becomes like a Catamari of fucking orgy sex going down the street.
I don't think it's possible for everyone to do.
I think everyone will do it.
I don't think it's possible.
I think most people are going to panic.
Most people are gonna they're not going to be able to,
yeah,
they're not going to be a little bit sorry to keep it together.
I don't think they're going to be able to just get hard on.
So just start banging,
you know,
hard ons,
choir,
like,
you know,
the feeling the need to breed,
like to need to be comfortable.
You have to be like secure.
You know,
a fucking rock is going to come and slam into the earth.
within the first second that the meteor impact the one that,
uh,
hit the Yucatan and killed the dinosaurs within the first second.
It was five miles deep into the earth within the first second.
Dude.
That's crazy dude.
Stop and think about that.
Within the first second,
it was five miles deep into the earth.
It killed everything.
It killed everything on earth is like some rats and shit survived some bugs,
a few bugs and some rats and they had to rebuild from scratch.
It killed everything 65 million years ago.
Wow.
And it's happened many times.
There's been several extinction events on earth.
They know there's another one from 250 million years ago that is another one
killed everybody shot Boehm and people will try to tell you like there's a way
they're going to be able to deflect them.
They don't even know they're common man.
Some of them come from behind the sun and yeah,
you can't see them.
Some of them come from weird places that no one's watching.
They're just,
they're all out there man.
And if they hit
would go right to sex though.
I think I could get it up.
I think I would like go over to my neighbor's house
and ask the girl like,
Hey,
do you want to join us?
I think I would think I would.
I would want to find out when they were thinking that it was going to hit and
then I'd do mushrooms.
Yeah,
that'd be good.
Mushrooms some faster though.
Full blown when it hit,
I try to do something faster.
Yeah.
But mushrooms seems like the right thing to do.
I understand about doing something faster,
but it seems like if you could get the timing right,
right.
Mushrooms [inaudible] bad ass.
Yeah.
Just keep eating them,
you know,
GPA,
get to get to like,
you know,
the hour and 20 minutes in.
And if it's still like the size of the moon in the sky,
I would shoot up heroin.
That would be the only time I would shoot up heroin.
I would just go right to heroin.
Fucking do a shitload of it has sex.
It's very fascinating to me that we have this horrifying fear of,
of dying something like something like that.
Any sort of a natural disaster or any big crazy thing as tsunami,
a meteor crash or,
but we all know that we're going to die.
Right?
It's like for some reason we don't want to address that.
We don't want to think about that.
We,
we want to think like,
how crazy would it be if it's going to die?
Catastrophe is that worse somehow than dying slow because your body stops
working,
right?
Or getting cancer or you know,
you look at some old people that,
you know,
every now and then you'll be out there like a,
I was in,
um,
I forget what city it was.
Montreal maybe.
And,
uh,
we were,
we were outside and there was a lady that was walking by,
I think it was Montreal and she had the,
the worst posture I've ever seen ever.
She was literally like bending at the waist.
Like she was doing it like an exercise like her,
her upper body was touching almost her legs and she was walking forward and she
was walking around.
I was like,
man,
that's a tough way to to die,
you know,
to die slow where your body just starts giving out and things start going wrong
and you have all these health issues in your organism is barely keeping it
together.
Wouldn't it be cool to die in a meteor impact dude,
if you're there where it hits five miles into the ground,
show
that the last,
the last 10 seconds and be so cool.
God,
you can know about.
You feel like you'd probably just burn up first or something.
I don't know.
I think the impact is like a billion nuclear explosion.
There's probably a lot of suction to when it comes at you so fast.
It's probably some weird vacuum that happens and then you just start flying
away.
You know?
Maybe,
maybe I don't have to be something weird like that.
Whatever.
The impact would probably kill everybody.
The [inaudible] they said that that one in Nevada.
Have you ever seen that one?
You fly over it.
It's like a mile wide.
You know that one?
Yeah.
That one was like not that big.
It wasn't a big thing and it killed everything within 800 miles.
Wow.
Everything.
That's crazy.
Everything 800 miles away from that thing just was evaporated.
Can you imagine me an 800 miles away from a meteor impact and you still get
jacked,
like you're watching it in the distance.
Where's it going to hit?
It's like 800 miles from that will be fine.
800 miles away it hits boom and you just disintegrate your thought.
Fuck.
It seems like something that you would talk about more often.
It seems like something that we would be addressing,
but I guess people just feel helpless and it hasn't really happened.
While we've been here and there's no reason to stress on it,
you know,
cause of your stress on anything too much.
It's just,
you know why stress on that.
It's true.
There's no reason to stress on it,
but it's still,
you would think that more people would want to discuss it.
We know another one hit Jupiter recently.
Really recently,
like within the last couple of years,
huge asteroid hit Jupiter.
There's probably groups of people that you know meet at places.
I can talk about asteroids if you're to do,
I can do some googling for you.
I wouldn't,
why would it go to groups when I could just talk to them online?
I'm not sure.
You know you could go to any a billion websites where guys were famous for
finding,
but they might make it fun.
They might get pizzas.
Staring at the stars is fun as fuck.
Yeah,
don't get me wrong.
I'm not an asteroid efficient.
I know he should be.
Brian,
I'm going to hit you fucking crazy asshole kind of podcast.
You try to present here,
boy,
it just too fucking weird man.
You wear people out,
whatever.
And now that you're on the hunt again,
weird.
All the bitches are you weird down to bitches or they take your style.
I seeing you and a,
I see,
I see what you've been doing and I'm very impressed.
You're doing good work.
How's that working?
Great.
Do you like being in second life?
Do you like having a girlfriend?
What do you know?
You know,
I,
I like having both.
I think being single is fun.
I think dating,
you want to kind bond.
Right now I'm just having fun because my,
I'm still motivated with stand up comedy that I'm just excited about that right
now,
so I don't even,
where can the folks here go stock you?
When are you gonna do standup again?
Well,
I,
I'm my Twitter.
I always announce if I'm usually doing the twitters,
redbox,
they have a show October 27th I have a part of this competition at a flappers
comedy club in Burbank.
It's called like Clyde's comedy content stack.
The deck.
Yeah.
We're going to stack the deck.
It's a couple of two for ones will stay,
will stack the audience with people listening to the park.
That would be awesome.
Yeah.
But 80% will be haters.
Yeah,
they would all be,
I'm fucking,
you were telling me,
say something Jay,
you ruin the whole show room.
The momentum.
We're trying to talk about some MMA.
You had to put your gay shit in.
You got to start talking.
KCA Pauline.
I love to hate.
Um,
so uh,
have you bombed yet?
Uh,
and your return?
No,
not really.
I mean it's really hard to bomb it or something like five people in there,
you know,
it's more of just like,
so these are like sort of like open mic night shows.
There was a lot of open makers in the audience.
Well yeah,
there's shows that I do.
They're like five people or this show supposedly,
I don't know how many people are going to get it,
but this is going to be like a legit show.
I did that like a show the other day in front of like 40,
40 people are so fucking destroyed.
It destroyed.
That was the first time I destroyed Everett,
like I came off and people were like,
yeah,
so did you say October 22nd October 27th I believe would day is that it's,
I believe a Wednesday if if it's the right date that I did.
Right,
and that's at flappers comedy club,
which is an awesome comedy club in downtown Burbank.
They took an old 27th it's a Wednesday.
Yeah,
so I'm going to be there too.
I'll be so hoarding Brian in this endeavor and,
and even you got to clap and cheer it.
Oh my gay jokes and act like they're really cool.
I can't do that.
You have to be fake.
If it's not,
it was not good.
I'm not going to laugh.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I can't treat you with kid gloves he to,
but if I get super high,
I'll probably think most things will fall away.
So I'll just go there.
Completely inebriated and laugh.
Just try to remember your jokes.
I saw Joey Diaz,
he did a CD recording the other day in Hollywood.
He didn't want us go in there.
Yeah,
it's actually going to go on a date there and every snuck in.
Man.
I heard.
I wasn't,
um,
uh,
well he was really good,
you know,
it was,
and it was interesting.
He told a bunch of stories that I hadn't heard before,
which I really didn't think was possible.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
it was the craziest thing ever.
Um,
he told some crazy fucking stories,
you know,
I don't want to,
uh,
give it away.
But one of them was about mugging a hooker.
I don't know how bad he felt about it for years later.
It was really fun.
Or Morris?
It was,
yeah,
it was good though.
It was a,
it was a good bit.
It's like funny how he lives,
like guilt and I have the same kind of guilt,
but my shit.
And I was like throwing rocks at it at Cardinal,
you know,
when I was at a kid and they threw a rock at a cardinal.
Yeah.
Like there's a little injured bird and it was a kid would throw rocks at it.
And I,
I think about that and that,
that shit all the time.
And,
uh,
his shit's like fucking mugged a hooker.
Do you know that?
They just pulled the miners out of the,
uh,
the shaft and Chile.
Are they alive?
Last minute worked on,
look,
this is CNN.
CNN is getting crushed.
This is cnn.com.
Look at it.
It's getting crushed.
They sh they cut all the,
they changed their whole page because they're getting so many hits.
I think cremate,
everything's smaller.
Look at their imagery of refresh.
Is that browser thing?
That's just when I'm brought for hitting a refresh.
I got it right here while the browser's fucking up because they're getting hit
so many times because the last minute work done ahead of Chilean mine rescue.
Yeah.
The descent capsule.
The descent of the capsule that will carry 33 miners trapped.
What are these guys doing for poop down there?
They just shitting in a corner.
Probably eating it.
It's probably like a never ending cycle of eating your own poop.
Just to stay alive in your own piss and eat your own cooking.
I had corn before I went into this mind.
Well you can do,
um,
you can eat your own poop.
Indians used to do it,
they just call it second harvest actually had,
this is 100% true story.
I had to write a paper about ways to help,
uh,
like it was like Africa or something like that and I was seriously read a paper.
It was like we used to send them a whole bunch of corn can,
they could wash it out and it read it twice probably.
And it was completely,
I tried to be completely legit.
I was in fifth grade and I got in so much trouble for that fucking report
because they thought it was just being an asshole on gross and stuff like that.
He was being completely serious.
Like I wrote it all fancy.
I see that movie.
The yes man.
No.
Yes.
Men was a movie.
Yes they did.
That parody where they were,
they said they were going to take,
you know,
make burgers at a poofter came out of the toilet.
They're going to filter it.
Yes.
No,
I didn't see you didn't see it.
It was like a
parody.
They did.
Well,
they did this,
they trolled people and they pretended that they were going to open up this
plant and they going gonna make cheeseburgers that are made out of poop cow.
Wow.
Yeah.
Seems familiar,
but,
well,
you know what man?
Uh,
it's,
it's a,
it's a brilliant movie.
You got to watch it.
A billion documentary.
I think they're doing something else too.
But you know,
think about how hard life has to be before you start eating your own shit.
You know,
the American Indians,
that was the roughest way to live ever.
You know,
before the Europeans came in,
think about what,
what it must've been like before there was even horses.
These fucking people were all on foot and they're eating their own poop.
I just is alive though.
Yeah,
they're,
mine was 33 of them,
man,
that's just jacked.
Nobody died.
And I went down.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't understand what they were doing down there.
Uh,
I mean,
I understand what they were doing.
That's how,
I mean,
I don't understand how they were staying alive.
They must've been in some sort of a,
um,
they might have places down there like where they can go in case or some sort of
a collapse of,
it's not collapsed with the whole mind,
you know,
it's called collapse of part of the mind.
They have like a rescue center.
All right.
Cause it seemed like there was some place they were going that was like set up
for,
you know,
if something like this happen,
there's a movie that came out is kind of on the subject that I recently came out
that you should I heard is disturbing as fuck.
It's called the human centipede and it's based,
it's based on uh,
I guess real science scientific experiments.
Have you heard of this base?
The real side to the experience that it was.
All right.
So that part of the trolley,
yeah,
I heard it was actually based on facts.
Well maybe the Nazis might've done something like that or like Japanese,
some crazy experience.
World War Two,
they did some crazy shit right.
Where they transfused horse
blood into people and there's a lot of,
they did amputation exercises and you try to,
you know,
put people's heads on other people's bodies and show that there's a lot of
things.
You
know what the,
the centipede connect people's butts to their mouths and they see if they could
keep making it a lot.
Yeah.
It's a hard movie,
Bro.
Yeah,
it is a horror movie that's supposed to be a terrible horror movie.
It's all based on scientific.
I swear to God that that was real.
So they're pulling people out,
man.
Wow.
They lowered the capsule.
I wonder how many people gave in and fucked each other.
Like let's have some minor sex.
Might as well [inaudible] there.
I'll give you black lung with mine.
I wonder how long it takes before people start doing shit like that.
You know?
I think some people would have different time tables and make it like,
to me,
I'd be happy masturbating forever for life.
I would look at a canary or if you went to jail for life.
For Life,
yeah.
I would totally just be happy masturbating.
Just like some sweet,
sweet boy wants to suck your Dick did.
Unless it was like,
like Justin Bieber style or something like that.
So you would do it if it was a little boy.
So do it if you looked under it.
Yeah.
No,
I'm just kidding.
to me,
I am happy with masturbation.
I think masturbation is great.
I have no problem.
Now if I'm in jail and I have nothing to look at it,
I'd probably have to draw my own women and stuff like that,
you know?
And that would draw you.
We'll just go from memory.
You'd go for your own after a while you won't have memory anymore.
Would you?
Would you kind of get to foggy?
Have some memories from my childhood.
I would drop right when he got in there and draw a vagina and boobs and stuff
just so I have references.
Never what they look like.
Yeah.
You would think that at least they could get them some fucking pulling her in
jail,
man.
That shit was fake,
right?
Like that where you're allowed to have sex dates or is that Rio?
No.
In some prisons they have it set up like that.
They would,
they would allow them to have conjugal visits where they're allowed to have sex.
Yeah.
They do that in some places,
but I don't know if that happens anymore.
Does that still going on?
I don't know.
I see.
I never knew he existed to begin with,
so yeah,
it was a real deal.
I don't know.
I'm not,
I'm not hip to what's going on in prison these days.
There's a lot of God damn prison shows on TV though.
Have you seen the one with the booty bandit?
You gotta talks about booty [inaudible] one of the most frightening things ever.
I'm going to load it up because,
uh,
you need to,
to know that this,
these guys like this waiting for you.
There's guys like this guy.
I'm waiting for you in prison.
I can only,
yeah,
the Buddhi warrior.
Okay.
I'm going to load this shit up.
Wasn't that,
that's fine.
Buried deeper homosexuality areas,
sexuality.
You have it on twice somewhere.
No,
I only have it on here.
You have to eat your windows up.
Yeah,
but it's not the same thing.
This is something else.
That's something else.
I only have it in here.
Oh,
what's this one?
All right.
Yes,
this is it.
I said plain twice.
I don't know.
You're the fake tech support here.
I bet.
Police told us about the place police told us was,
you have the use that's,
oh,
is that what it is?
Yeah.
Jesus.
This is the most unprofessional setup ever.
Tow free.
Call you console free.
They're trying to sell me real estate.
Order that answer that.
No,
but when lockup visited Kentucky state penitentiary,
we met police jobs a long time in men who practices are very different kind of
homosexuality.
Well,
we have sexual desires.
Right?
Locked up.
You got warm place all along.
Oh Lord.
Oh,
hold on.
I'm calling him out on that safety.
Do Five.
So when I'd be home,
do all made them happen.
[inaudible] is going out to people's mood.
Does it say the most memorable story that the police told us?
This is why David Hale,
one of the producers and I met this dude.
He talked to them about this meeting within a maximum security penitentiary and
he went on about it and on about it.
And it's prison.
Do you want,
um,
more important for Armenians,
but,
hmm.
It was more broad job,
sir.
It looked booming.
I have lots of booty.
One more drink and drinking water.
Was that guy projecting like as I no feeling and he's just like,
yeah,
everybody likes it more than water.
I don't know
whether he's just trying to beat sensational for the TV show and just like
really freak everybody out.
I don't know if he just likes fucking people that much.
He just loves beauty that much I think.
I think he personally would like to ask some more than anything.
Well he's talking about how it's,
that's how they rock it in jail.
I mean you got,
he's the only one in jail.
You got to think there's a possibility that he's telling the truth that
everybody's just running around fucking everybody.
Is that if you have probably like a life sentence,
there's probably a good 70% of people that just flip over.
I don't.
Yeah,
I don't think I would,
but I don't,
I'm not putting that situation.
You were in jail with this guy though,
that guy.
You will.
You got to give up the booty.
You think you can fight them off?
Yeah,
he's got a weak chin.
I don't like that.
You think you can fight them off or no,
you don't like to wait?
Like if he attacks me,
give up the booty.
If he attacks me,
raped you.
Ah,
fuck.
I don't know that guy.
I can beat that guy.
Really?
You think you could beat this big black dangerous rape dude?
If he likes asked that much,
I could totally beat that guy.
Well,
let's see what this is.
How he would take the pussy tells guys how it takes the boy pussy.
I like boot Johnson went on to tell our crew how we used to satisfy his sexual
desires,
especially during the 1970s and eighties when he was most active in personal
security was more lax one out to see one.
Any school to me when I go see him,
I'll say
mountain,
you are.
Um,
I like you mulch
and we can do it the easy way out a hallway.
Solid.
Chauncey,
y'all on the phone.
We can do this thing
easy way or the hard way.
The choice is yours,
right?
What'd you do,
Brian?
If he said that to me,
I'd be like,
all right,
but let me get down on your first and then like you'll take his pants off,
right?
And I would just like fucking start karate chopping his dick as hard as I could.
Do you really think that's gonna work?
First of all,
you'd probably be hypnotized by it.
Like a Cobra to a flute.
I would probably look at that big giant black fucking snake in front of you.
You might start [inaudible] out of fear.
I would probably grab it as hard as I could run as fast as I could.
You would tap it off
to the worst Magog class ever.
You would be though the worst self defense instructor of all time.
Okay.
This is what we want to do.
No,
I probably would do some tech story.
I'd probably like,
could you imagine if you had,
this is your fucking plan.
Imagine if somebody hired someone to do like a rape prevention course and you
were the guy and that you would come in and you were totally unqualified.
I W we're going to grab the Dick.
We're going to run as hard as we can.
We're going to try to rip it off.
You'd have all these people were practicing,
like if he's got his dick and it's on the floor,
do you think he's going to be worried about hurting you or getting his ticket
tach back to his body?
He's not going to spend the time to kick your ass.
Trust me.
If you pull his dick off,
the fight is over.
I called this move.
Picking up the phone book,
take the grab,
grab the balls as hard as you can and just pull it up as fast as you can own
book.
Yeah,
imagine that.
Imagine if you were to do that.
Like if you're like,
all right,
let me go down on you and you take,
you take his balls in both of your hand and take two handfuls is hard as you can
crab and you just dig your claws in and just like Paul and,
and rip as fast as you can.
Well,
you might be able to rip someone's testicles off,
right?
It might be possible.
Someone's test scores.
You have a good grip.
If you knew you were going to get raped in prison,
wouldn't you do something like this?
Balls were all sweaty.
Then they slipped right out.
Oh,
that's what you have to dig.
My nails are courts,
ankle slips right out.
And then you've got,
what are you going to do now?
He's going to beat the fuck out.
He tried to grab his balls.
Yeah.
Dig your nails in,
man.
Go for it.
Put your finger underneath the vein.
That's where that would be.
Your self defense would always be attack the ball,
the ball off with two hands.
It's that dude in prison.
Decimal that style.
Yeah.
What if he punches you first?
Uh,
I don't care about you first.
I'm going to write for his shit.
He punches you in the face before he even makes you suck his dick just Bob
Bland.
Just to let you know,
this is how it's going down.
Well,
I probably wouldn't wipe my ass too much when I was in prison.
So even if he did knock me down and he went for,
you'd be like,
oh,
this shit stinks.
I can't go from the chest.
You would sacrifice and you'd be itchy all to get used to it.
Probably get used to it.
This guy scares the fuck out of me,
man.
That guy is crazy.
It's fucking crazy for me.
Things like half of me thinks he's just all fucking fake.
I don't think so,
dude.
I'm willing.
I think it's true.
You know?
I mean,
I don't think there's a whole lot of rape and he looks like cee Lo green though.
Can,
he's like,
I'm on,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
[inaudible] kit in general was also had a ward,
but the new generation of inmates,
they might be asking for trouble from old timers and old.
They get this by what they say the pain is they for this will stay on in
college.
Some.
Some of them will stay on if you know this too.
All right.
See what they want for pile up.
It's my fault.
You said you'll pray with it.
Her man,
somebody be up in your cart,
you know,
and it did that.
So
it looks like Randy from American idol.
I'm not scared of that guy.
When
he was in his prime,
they wouldn't be saved from Ajay advantages either.
The camera man,
he's saying [inaudible] in her back then and as much starlight booty off
probably that want to know,
but hey,
now we're bronco pains and then do the,
this
[inaudible] got no shame in my game.
This is nothing that I'm ashamed to admit.
I am what I am to you and all of a sudden warrior [inaudible],
I'm a warrior.
I'm a booty stealing warrior.
See to me,
I see the gay in that guy and to me it just sounds like he's just like,
I'm going to get him.
I want to get his butt hole.
He and I'm like,
that doesn't scare me in jail for life.
Are you crazy?
He's probably murdered of gang of people and he will fuck you up if you were
alone in a cage with that guy.
And he pulled out his black digging and we go and do this.
The easy way,
all the hobbies,
weight started dropping fucking knuckles on your face.
You think you can jack up his balls off so you'd be willing to,
if I can get this guy parole,
do you'd be willing to do I occasion match with him?
No.
No,
I'm not saying cage match.
I'm just saying if I'm in a cell with him and he approaches me,
I'll be,
I'll go for it.
Oh,
I will totally suck your big black day and then I'll go down like I'm going to
do it.
Just start ripping shit up.
And you think that would work.
Totally.
We're totally fucking snap his dick and happen every good boy.
He's still in the cage with you and now he's hurt.
Yeah.
In doing it.
I'm going to keep on doing it.
You're going to start crying.
Nobody comes to your rescue.
Never start kicking his little ball hole wherever it falls were
fucking,
I'm Geez.
Little Boho murder him from the Dick.
So yes,
totally.
But what if as you're going down to go to his dick,
he needs you in the face?
No,
because he doesn't know.
He thinks I'm going down on him to suck his dick and I was good actor.
I'm a totally good,
I don't think you're going to come off.
She never asked.
You'll throw on a gay voice.
Oh,
totally.
I'll totally break out and everything.
I would fucking as an analyst of a altercations,
which I am,
I'm an altercation at a an altercation analyst.
I think you're fucked in this one.
Yeah,
I think he's going to be looking for you to do something like that.
It's probably other guys tried to grab his dick before you think you gotta be
the first person.
I'll drag them if I can look these guys,
he's going to punch you in your face a few times.
If I look them in the eyes and be released,
sincere with my voice and I'm like,
look,
I really think we should do this because we're going to be in here while he
likes rape.
What have you,
doesn't get hard.
Look the normal way.
I'll be like,
look,
first I want to lick you off.
You know?
I'll say so I can.
He's obviously not bright guy.
I could trick him with my words and my eyes.
We doesn't seem that dumb.
He just seemed to fuck.
He's in prison.
He got caught.
Well,
he's a criminal,
Brian.
A lot of them are just,
they're doing so much crime.
They just will get caught.
You gotta be smart.
Dexter didn't get caught.
Oh,
Brian,
I think he would rape you.
All right.
Okay.
I don't think he'd raped me,
but I think he'd raped you.
I think a,
we'd have a problem though if he and I were in jail together.
Hmm.
I don't think you would not try to rape me.
I think he definitely works.
I think.
Yeah,
I think you'd probably tried to,
everybody smoked cigarettes though.
Sorry,
I've got a question.
His gas tank.
Why are we always talking about gay sex on this shit?
Cause we're,
we're targeting how many people are like assholes until this is fascinating
fucking guy man.
This isn't just talking about gay sex.
What's fascinating to me is about this guy being so brazen about it,
but he's just talking about it and like
he's obviously loving the attention at all.
Those cameras are putting on them.
So I'm trying to figure out how much of this is true.
I'm trying to figure out how much of it is just he's,
you know,
exaggerating everything to seem even cooler for this TV show because he knows
they're going to air them and he's probably a fucking star now.
They have TV in prison so they probably have seen this show and som saying I,
he probably went out and tried to rape somebody that night just to fucking
celebrate.
Right.
I don't know.
What if he can probably listen to this podcast and he's sitting there fucking
like,
if I get ever get out here,
I'm going to show this boy,
I'll beat that dude.
Don't worry about it bro.
We'll get him.
We'll get him before he comes near you.
Thanks.
I would suck.
There's no way we can end the show this way,
but yet we are doing it.
I would buy that guy a fleshlight like,
dude,
wait,
calm down second.
That's not what he wants.
Or the Guy Asshole.
Maybe he likes it.
They have butthole flashlights.
It doesn't feel as good.
Holding a person down the whole.
You'd be in panic and your blood,
sweat and all that.
He'd probably,
that's what you probably looked forward to.
Probably looks forward to the whole domination aspect of it is we've officially
crossed the line and uh,
talked about way too much gay shit on this podcast.
No more gay shit.
The entire next podcast.
Yes.
Next.
Next podcast has to be a all gay humor free.
Yes.
Um,
uh,
Brody Stevens.
Uh,
you guys are great.
Thank you for tuning in.
This was a very strange,
like this podcast.
What are strange?
I think we did get a little bit too high because when I started talking about
the,
um,
the tea party,
I started talking about it.
I was like,
you know what?
I don't really even know what they like.
I started talking shit about them and I'm like,
I don't even know what a,
what's annoying me about them?
They may be delightful people.
No,
they're definitely not delighting people there.
They're ridiculous.
You're fucking ridiculous.
It,
it's just gave voters,
they're all crazy.
I don't know what their stance is,
but I know they're crazy personally here.
Glenn Beck and fucking Sarah Palin talking farm.
So I wouldn't have even gone down that road.
I don't think you felt wasn't so high.
But since I've been high,
I've been forced to take a position.
My position is,
they're crazy.
When that guy who dresses up like a Nazi,
uh,
for sure,
he said nigger somewhere in his life for sure.
Right?
He doesn't like Jews.
You think that he has ever touched a child?
It could be.
It could be touched a child.
He's,
something's wrong with that dude.
There's definitely something very,
very wrong with him.
Um,
you know,
you,
you don't,
you don't go around dressing like the most evil fucks that ever existed when
people still alive were detained by these people and their families were killed.
That's,
that's,
that's like people that are alive right now.
It's one thing if you want to dress up like a fucking barbarian,
you know,
and put a big bear skin fucking thing on and crazy bone like teeth,
like necklaces and stuff.
Do you want to dress like somebody who looks like who was the enemy,
right?
10,000 years ago,
but not in 1945.
All right.
Stop.
Right,
right.
Can you imagine the future when they have like browser reenactments?
Like they,
you know,
like reenactments from like companies.
Like,
all right,
I'm going to play
the role of Microsoft.
Yeah.
I'm going to play a role as you know,
and we're going to mildly bore each other for the next two hours to teach our
kids what happened.
That's why.
Could you imagine if someone who wants to play Steve Jobs or I'm Steve Jobs and
I'm Steve Wasniak and we created apple.
Right?
And they're dressing the part.
Yeah.
I'll reenactments
tarted.
It doesn't matter what you're reenacting with its software wars or civil wars,
like what are you doing?
You're,
you're,
you're getting together and play pretending.
Don't you have a family?
You Fuck,
you know,
don't you have a life?
Don't you have things to do?
Nope.
No,
no.
We don't either.
That's why we did the podcast today.
That's right.
And you're going to be going to London for UFC.
Yes.
Going to London and,
uh,
we'll be back next Tuesday with Bobby Lee.
Bobby Lee wants to do it next Tuesday and maybe Joe Diaz will join us again if
he can break free of his other,
uh,
commitments.
Joe Dia's is a wanted man these days though.
He's got a lot of shit going on.
[inaudible] he,
uh,
you know,
did the CD taping the other night,
right?
The other thing he's going to do more of them.
There was only like,
you know,
it wasn't like the biggest crowd there.
They weren't sure whether or not they were going to record.
They weren't sure whether or not they're going to have the room because it's,
um,
it's all,
uh,
the,
south comedy hall has,
they lost their liquor license or some sort of occupancy problem cause something
that landlord did.
So they're opening up a new club.
So he's going to have a new club and like a couple of weeks.
And if you live anywhere near Santa Ana and 10 days are going to be at this
sweet ass theater called the galaxy theater.
It looks bad ass.
The Santa Ana Galaxy Theater is,
um,
that is on the 22nd at 10.
Uh,
yeah,
I think there's still some tickets available for that.
And uh,
that's going to be a good time.
I don't even know how I'm doing it with probably Joey,
if Joey's around,
if he's free that night.
And uh,
that weekend is the UFC.
So this weekend to UFC,
weekends in a row,
this one's in London.
I got two shows at the Lester Square theater.
And um,
then of course the 16th,
it's on Spike TV and then UFC one 21 is the 23rd.
And that one is,
uh,
on paper view and it's going to be fucking crazy.
So that's it.
That's the end of the program.
Thank you very much for tuning in,
ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
we,
uh,
enjoy you all.
We appreciate you all.
We wish we had something to end the show with.
Let's do that.
That,
that,
uh,
Deanwood song.
Yeah,
hit me.
Hit me with that shit cause it just came out today.
So next Tuesday,
Bobby Lee and um,
we'll definitely do another one next week too,
for,
you know,
I don't know who will do figure on campus.
I don't get Dunkin back on this shit.
Oh,
doctor was supposed to be back,
but he had a problem with buttholes poopy.
See Ya later.
Everybody.
Fuck every single one.